ओके
सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव गाइस देख लेते हैं
वेट करते हैं आन देते सबको चलो तो या
फिलहाल हम लाइव आ चुके
हैं लाइव लाइव गाइस ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही
है इस बता दीजिए एक बार जल्दी से ऑडियो
वीडियो सब
एकदम टकाटक है ना झकास बिल्कुल बढ़िया ना
जल्दी बता दो जल्दी बता दो सभी बता दो
जल्दी आ जाओ आ जाओ चलो आने देते सबको भाई
आज की क्लास
में ओके गुड इवनिंग भाई गुड
इवनिंग नमस्ते भाई गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते राधे
राधे बढ़िया
सब माय फर्स्ट लाइव वीडियो विथ यू क्या
बात है ग्रेट ग्रेट अच्छी बात है आगे के
लाइव में भी कंटिन्यू रहिएगा आप लोग
चलिए यहां पर देख लेते हैं यहां पर चैट
ओपन कर लेते हैं मैंने आपको बोला ना चैट
आज मजा आएगा आज के सेशन में काफी मजा आएगा
देखते हैं कितना मजा आता है आज के क्लास
में मैं कंप्लीट पूरी इंटरेक्शन करूंगा
आपके साथ फुल
इंटरेक्शन फुल इंटरेक्शन होगी आपके साथ
बातचीत होगी मजे आएंगे कमाल होगा
बढ़िया बढ़िया
बढ़िया हां एपी की का इंपैक्ट तो नहीं
बताओगे तो कैसे काम चलेगा भाई बिना
इंपैक्ट का तो कुछ भी नहीं है इंपैक्ट तो
बताना पड़ेगा भाई सीधी सी बात है बिना
इंपैक्ट का क्या ही
होगा मैं सामने फोन को सामने रख लेता
हूं ताकि
आपकी
ओके ठीक है नमस्ते भाई नमस्ते नमस्ते चलिए
तो आपके जो भी सवाल है गाइस आप लोगों के
आज सवालों की लाइन लगा दीजिए आज हम सवाल
जवाब करने वाले हैं बहुत सारा बहुत सारी
जो बातें हैं ना वह करने वाले हैं एंड
बहुत सारी चीजें डिस्कस करेंगे एंड आज के
जो मैंने आप लोगों से पॉल में क्वेश्चन
आपसे किया था राइट सभी से ग्रुप जो है
हमारा बग बाउंट वाला उसमें मैंने पॉल में
क्वेश्चन किया आपसे ठीक है यहां पे मैं
दिख नहीं रहा क्या ठीक से एक सेकंड रुक
जाओ एक सेकंड एक सेकंड
अन हां जी अब सही है तो मैंने पॉल में आप
सबसे क्वेश्चन करा एंड आप सबने पॉल में
आंसर किया था कि भैया आज तो क्लास होनी
चाहिए न्यू टॉपिक आनी चाहिए यह वो डाउट
सेशन वाले बहुत कम लोग थे भाई तो डाउट
सेशन में क्या दिक्कत आ रही है सबको डाउट
सेशन डाउट नहीं होते क्या तुम्हारे यह
बताओ मुझे डाउट नहीं आते क्या किसी को चलो
हेलो नौ
सखिया थैंक यू भाई आई एम कूल थैंक यू दीपक
वर्मा हेलो वसीम बढ़िया
अविनाश हेलो अविनाश हेलो लिरिकल बग अली
ओके बबू चक क्या नाम है भाई नमस्ते सेमन
राधे राधे राधे राधे भाई सबको वेन यू विल
क प्लान मीट अप इन पाकिस्तान अरे भाई देख
लो पाकिस्तान में मीटअप करवाने की पूछ रहा
है भाई य मतलब यार एक बताओ इंडिया में तो
मीटअप मैंने अभी तक कराया ही नहीं अभी तक
इंडिया में मीटअप नहीं हो
पाया ड्यू टू सेवरल रीजन तुम पाकिस्तान
में मीटअप की बोल रहे हो यार
ऐसे कैसे चलेगा
भाई करेंगे या पाकिस्तान में भी आ जाएंगे
कभी कभी पाकिस्तान आना हुआ तो आएंगे
बिल्कुल
आएंगे बट मैं पाकिस्तान अकेले नहीं आऊंगा
यार मैं पाकिस्तान सनी पाजी के साथ ही
आऊंगा याद रखना भाई ऐसे अकेले आने में
दिक्कत है भाई पाकिस्तान में पाकिस्तान
पाकिस्तान में जाने से काफी डर लगता है
एक्चुअली काफी काफी डर लगता है यार कहीं
भी बम ब्लास्ट हो जाते हैं कहीं भी कुछ भी
हो जाता है थोड़ा सा तो डर लगता है हल्का
फुल्का
तो इसको दिल पर नहीं लेने का
लेकिन पाकिस्तान सेफ नहीं है अभी फिलहाल
के लिए
चलो हां नेपाल तो ठीक है बढ़िया
यार सो प्लीज ऑर्गेनाइज मीट अप इन इंडिया
हां जी ऑर्गेनाइज करेंगे मीट अप देखो डाउट
सेशन में जल्दी आ गए ज्यादा लोग वाह क्या
बात है अरे
भाई बढ़िया कासिम बढ़िया मैं एकदम मस्त
चकाचक चलिए और और कुछ यहां पर ठीक है कुछ
क्वेश्चंस ले लेते य पर क्वेश्चन आप लोग
पिक अप कीजिए क्वेश्चंस
पूछिए बढ़िया बढ़िया क्वेश्चन पूछिए
प्लीज चलिए हेलो सर जी दिस इज मंजिल मंजिल
फ्रॉम नेपाल एंड आई फॉलो योर वीडियो सिंस
डे वन एंड सम डेज आई एम रेगुलर एंड सम
टाइम्स नॉट माय डाउट इज हाउ मच टाइम इज
नीडेड टू फाइंड प्रॉपर बग अब देखो हाउ मच
टाइम नीडेड फॉर फाइंडिंग प्रॉपर बग यह तो
सवाल करेक्ट नहीं बोलूंगा मैं दिस इ नॉट
क्वेश्चन क्योंकि यह आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता
है टोटली आप किसी प्रोग्राम पर कितना टाइम
दे रहे हैं किस टाइप से प्रोग्राम को
सिलेक्ट कर रहे हैं वह भी काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
है आपका प्रोग्राम कैसा है कौन सी
प्रोग्राम आपने सिलेक्ट की है बक क्राउड
से हैकर वन से डॉक्स से एसवी हैक से
इंटीग्रिटी से या ऐसे जितने भी बग बाउंट
प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं बहुत सारे हैं 00 बग
बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स है हैकर वन और बक
क्राउड की तरह ठीक है मैं आपसे एक चीज और
बोलूंगा कि हैकर वन और बक क्राउड के अलावा
देरर मल्टीपल प्लेटफॉर्म्स जो बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम्स जो है वो बग बाउंट के
प्रोग्राम्स को लिस्ट करती है वहां
अटैकर्स जो है साइन अप करके एंड वहां पे
हंट कर सकते हैं आप ऐसे प्लेटफॉर्म्स पे
हंट कीजिए स्टार्टिंग में जो कॉमन ज्यादा
नहीं है जैसे बक क्राउड और हैकर वन को
छोड़ दीजिए मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम आप अगर बक
राउड प कर रहे हैं दैट वुड बी ग्रेट कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है करिए
लेकिन मैं यह कह रहा हूं कि अगर आपको
थोड़ा जल्दी कुछ फाइंड करना है तो कुछ ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स और स्कोप्स को ढूंढिए जो
यूजुअली कॉमन नहीं होता है बाकी लोगों को
वह नहीं मिल पा रहा है वहां भीड़ कम होगी
आपके चांसेस व बिलिटी फाइंड करने के
ज्यादा होंगे वैलिड बग मिलने के चांसेस
ज्यादा होंगे वहां पर आपको बाउंट मिलने के
चांसेस ज्यादा होंगे ट्स द थिंग ओके यह
चीज
है सर पाकिस्तान सेफ है पाकिस्तानी सेफ
नहीं है अच्छा यह बात है तो मुझे नहीं पता
था
सॉरी सर कैन यू टेक अ लाइव बग बाउंट सेशन
नमन गांधी अरे भाई नमन लेंगे लाइव बक
बाउंट सेशन ही चलती है बट हां मैं समझ गया
तुम्हारी भावना को लाइव हंटिंग की तुम बात
कर रहे हो लाइव हंटिंग भी कराएंगे बहुत
जल्द जब थोड़े कांसेप्ट में चीजों को बता
दूंगा ना ओस टॉप 10 को पूरी तरीके से कवर
कर दूंगा देन मैं लाइव हंटिंग पे भी आऊंगा
लाइक हम एक लाइव प्रोग्राम को एक स्कोप को
सेलेक्ट करेंगे एक प्रोग्राम चूज करेंगे
और उसपे रेगुलर हंट करेंगे ऐसा नहीं कि एक
क्लास में एक प्रोग्राम पे हंट करेंगे ना
एक प्रोग्राम चूज किया उस पे कम से कम
एटलीस्ट वी आर गोइंग टू हंट फॉर वन वीक एक
वीक तक हंट करेंगे हम और फिर देखेंगे कि
हम एक्चुअली क्या वहां पर फाइंड कर रहे
हैं तो दिस ऑल विल बी लाइव ठीक है और जो
भी क्वेश्चन आप पूछना प्लीज बहुत बार मत
रिपीट करना स्पैम टाइप लगता है ठीक
है हेलो भाई मेरे को मैक मैकबुक में ओस
ब्रोकेन वेब एप्लीकेशन स्लो डाउनलोड हो
रहा है प्लीज सलूशन दे दो डाउनलोड स्लो हो
रहा है इसका कोई सलूशन नहीं है भाई
इंटरनेट कनेक्टिविटी चेक
करो सर आई हैव रिपोर्टेड टू सिमी थापड़
सेइंग सर आई हैव रिपोर्टेड टू वने बिलिटी
इन थ्री डेज बट एवरी टाइम आई चूज द टारगेट
आई गेट कंफ्यूज फ्रॉम वयर टू स्टार्ट
आफ्टर द रेकन इज देयर एनी सॉल्यूशन टू दिस
हां जी सिम्मी ये बहुत बड़ी प्रॉब्लम है
काफी लोगों की आपको चेकलिस्ट बनानी पड़ेगी
सीधी सी बात है बिना चेकलिस्ट बनाए अगर आप
हंट करोगे तो आपको पता ही नहीं चलेगा कि
एक्चुअली आप कर क्या रहे हो उस प्रोग्राम
पे उस प्रोग्राम पे आप कौन सी विनेबिलिटी
फाइंड कर रहे हो करना चाहिए कौन सा कर
चुके हो क्या कर रहे हो तो आप एक चेकलिस्ट
बनाओ अगर आपसे चेकलिस्ट नहीं बन रहा है ओ
की चेकलिस्ट आती है जो मैंने एड ऐप हमारा
डेनिक्स अकेडमी उस पे भी अपलोड किया है
फ्री कोर्स जो है ₹10 वाले में उसमें आप
जाके उसमें में भी आप देख सकते हो उस
चेकलिस्ट के अकॉर्डिंग हंट करो सिंपल सा
सिंपल सा फंडा है ठीक है रिकॉन किया उसके
बाद चेकलिस्ट को फॉलो करो क्योंकि रिकॉन
मैं मानता हूं सबसे पहला स्टेप तुम्हारा
होना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से क्योंकि कोई भी
प्रोग्राम पे अगर रकॉन बढ़िया से कर लेते
हो तो तुम्हें बहुत सारी चीजें तो पहले ही
पता चल जाती है देन हंटिंग करने में आगे
जो चीजें करोगे उसमें काफी इजी आपको लगेगा
ठीक है काफी इजी पड़ता है वो फिर
ओके बिना चीट शट का सॉरी बिना आपके लाइक
एक पर्टिकुलर चेकलिस्ट के आगे हंट मत करो
दिक्कत होगी तुम्हें पर्टिकुलर चेकलिस्ट
एक बना लो यार
बस सर मुझे एपीआई की मिल रही है लेकिन मैं
उसको एक्सप्लोइट कैसे करूं जिससे मैं
बैकग्राउंड में डाल सकूं अब यह तो भाई
देखो यह तो डिपेंड करता है ना किस टाइप की
एपीआई की तुम्हें मिल रही है टेस्टिंग
एनवायरमेंट की मिल रही है प्रोडक्शन
एनवायरमेंट की मिल रही है डेवलपमेंट
एनवायरमेंट की मिल रही है किस टाइप की
एपीआई कीज मिल रही है उनका एक्चुअल
इंपैक्ट है क्या वो तुम उसको शो करना
पड़ेगा वही तुमको दिखाना है सामने
प्रोग्राम्स को भैया कि इस एपीआई की से हम
क्या-क्या चीजें एक्चुअली कर सकते हैं किस
लेवल की परमिशन को गेन कर सकते हैं बस वो
दिखा दोगे काम तुम्हारा बन जाएगा
दैट्ची
है
ओके सर विल यू मेक योर ओन सीटीएफ हमारा
खुद का सीटीएफ प्लेटफॉर्म भी आने वाला है
बहुत जल्द लॉन्च होगा तो उसपे हमारा खुद
का ही
क्रिएटेडटेड डेनिक्स के साइड से आपके लिए
ट्राई हैक म से बेटर एक ऑप्शन आने वाला है
और ट्राई हैक म से काफी सस्ता ऑप्शन आने
वाला है ठीक है डेफॉक्स लेकर आ रही है
बेसिकली आप उसपे क्या कर पाएंगे आप उसपे
सीटीएफ खेल पाएंगे चैलेंजेबल जस को सॉल्व
करेंगे वो
चैलेंजेबल किया रहेगा साइबर सिक्योरिटी के
हर एक डोमेन के लिए चाहे वो बग बाउंट हो
क्रिप्टोग्राफी हो नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी हो
या मैलवेयर एनालिसिस हो व्हाट एवर द डोमेन
इज आपको वहां पे अलग-अलग चैलेंजेबल जस
होंगे बाद में चैलेंज हम बढ़ाते जाएंगे
धीरे-धीरे एंड अभी आपको वो बिल्कुल फ्री
में यूज करने को मिलेगा बाद में
सब्सक्रिप्शन बेसिस हम लाएंगे बत वो बहुत
ही मिनिमल सब्सक्रिप्शन $5 के आसपास कुछ
ऐसा हम सब्सक्रिप्शन रखेंगे ऐसा नहीं
रखेंगे कि 000 000 आपको महीने का ले रहे
हैं तो वहां पे आपको एक्चुअल सीटीएफ
चैलेंजेबल
मिलेंगे जिसको सॉल्व करने में आपको दिमाग
यूटिलाइज काफी ज्यादा होगा ऐसे चैलेंज को
सॉल्व अगर आप कर लेंगे तो आपका
दिमाग पूरे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के हर एक
कोने-कोने को पकड़ लेगा हर एक चीज को पकड़
लेगा हर एक चीज को टैकल करेगा हर एक
टेक्निक को समझेगा एंड आपके जो भी
कांसेप्ट वो क्लियर हो जाएंगे ठीक है नहीं
भी होंगे तो उस चैलेंज में जो जो चीज आपको
मिलेंगी तो आपको उसके बारे में पढ़ना जब
पड़ेगा पढ़ के फिर आपका क्लियर हो
जाएगा सर आई एम इन स्टडिंग 10थ क्लास कैन
आई स्टडी बग बाउंट बिल्कुल पढ़ सकते हो
क्लास मैटर नहीं करती है बग बाउंटीज के
लिए या किसी भी तरह के नॉलेज के लिए ट्स
इट कोई भी क्लास मैटर नहीं करती आप 10थ
में हो 12थ में हो डजन मैटर ठीक है आपके
अंदर पैशन एक है आपके अंदर सीखने की ललक
है तो आप जरूर से सीखिए क्योंकि नॉलेज कभी
भी आपको लॉस नहीं कराएगी कहीं पर भी कोई
उसमें आपका नेगेटिव नेगेटिव कुछ आउटकम
आपको नहीं आएगा पॉजिटिव आउटकम ही आएगा जब
आपके पास अच्छी नॉलेज होती है ठीक है चलिए
और भी क्वेश्चन ले लेते हैं कुछ क्वेश्चन
यहां
पे बहुत सारे क्वेश्चंस नीचे आ है चलो और
भी क्वेश्चन है सर मेरा ओस सेटअप नहीं हो
रहा है ओस सेटअप क्यों नहीं हो रहा बहुत
इजी टू सेटअप है यार उसकी फाइल डाउनलोड
करो वम वेर में चला दो कहीं
पे ठीक है
अ सर मैं रिकॉन के बाद आगे नहीं बढ़ पा
रहा हूं पता नहीं आगे क्या करूं वही मैंने
बोला चेकलिस्ट इज मस्ट बिना चेकलिस्ट के
आगे बढ़ेंगे तो आगे आप एक्चुअली नहीं बढ़
पाएंगे चेकलिस्ट का मतलब होता है आप एक लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स जो लो हैंगिंग वनबिल होती
है जो बहुत ही सिंपल वले एबिलिटीज होती है
उनसे शुरू कीजिए धीरे-धीरे इंटरमीडिएट
लेवल की जो वलने बिलिटी आप मानते कंसीडर
करते हैं लाइक मीडियम जो सीबीएसएस स्कोर
वाले वलने बिलिटी सबसे पहले लो सीबीएसएस
स्कोर वाले वलने बिलिटी को लो हैंगिंग को
लिस्ट कीजिए फिर म मिड जो सीबीएसएस स्कोर
होते हैं उसको लाइए फिर क्रिटिकल वनबिल को
लिस्ट कीजिए ऐसे धीरे-धीरे ग्रैजुअली आगे
बढ़ी ठीक है एक चेकलिस्ट बनाइए उस
चेकलिस्ट के अकॉर्डिंग आप काम कीजिए ठीक
है देन आपका सब कुछ बढ़िया रहेगा एक
टारगेट लीजिए और एक टारगेट पे टारगेट पे
जैसे कोई एक टारगेट लिया आपने मान लो आपने
tesla.svs
क एक टारगेट है या yahoo.com कुछ कोई सा
भी है तो आप एक टारगेट पे एटलीस्ट वन वीक
तो एटलीस्ट हंट कीजिए स्टार्टिंग में अगर
आप एक न्यूकमर हैं बिगनर हैं तो आप 15 दिन
भी उसपे हंट कर सकते हैं लगातार या एक
महीना भी हंट कर सकते हैं डिपेंड करता है
आपका स्कोप क्या है अब क्या है ना हैकर्स
क्या करते हैं मल्टीपल टारगेट्स सर्च करके
करने के चक्कर में लगे रहते हैं क्यारे
भाई ये भी टारगेट है वो भी टारगेट है ये
भी कर लो उसमें भी कर लो उसपे भी हं कर
लेते हैं एक्चुअल चीज नहीं कर पाते
एक्चुअल चीज क्या नहीं कर पाते पता है
कि वो टारगेट का जो स्कोप एरिया है ना
उसको ब्रॉड नहीं कर पाते यह बहुत बड़ी
प्रॉब्लम है सबके प्रॉब्लम है इसको आपको
सही कर लेना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से जब आप
कोई टारगेट चूज करते हो स्कोप चूज करते हो
ना उसको वाइड स्कोप बनाओ एक ही टारगेट को
इतना स्प्रेड अप कर दो आपके पास इतने आपके
अंदर उसके अंदर में इतने सब टारगेट हो गए
ना कि आप उन पर हंट करो मेरे कहने का मतलब
है ना टारगेट का स्कोप इंक्रीज करो बस
जितना कर सकते हो जितनी चीजें उससे
रिलेटेड चीजें हैं उसको फाइंड कर सकते हो
आपके लिए हेल्पफुल
होगी क्या बोल रहे भाई सर ए पेनेट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग कोर्स के बारे में भी बता दीजिए
अरे ये हां ए पेन टेस्टिंग कोर्स के बारे
में पहले भी बता दिया है मैंने वैसे बट
ठीक है फिर भी मैं बता देता हूं सिंपल सा
फंडा है एंड पेन टेस्टिंग कोर्स जो है वो
ऑलरेडी आपकी 18th में से स्टार्ट हो रही
है एंड सीट्स ऑलरेडी फुल हो चुकी है जो
ऑफर प्राइस में सीट्स थी वो फुल है ठीक है
तो उसमें कोई सीट्स नहीं बची हुई थी बट
स्टिल हमने क्या किया हमने सीट्स बढ़ा
मतलब इन द सेंस कि हमने 17 तक वो ऑफर कर
दिया कि लाइक 17 तक भी कोई अगर इनरोल करता
है तो उसको सेम ऑफर फी में 50 पर
डिस्काउंट वाले में वह इनरोल कर सकता है
तो आप इनरोल कर सकते हैं मैं लिंक दे देता
हूं एंड पेन
टेस्टिंग लाइव ट्रेनिंग एनरोल हियर ठीक है
मैंने यहां प लिंक दे दिया है आप यहां
लिंक पर जाकर डिटेल्स चेक आउट भी कर सकते
हैं एंड नरोल भी कर सकते हैं जो मर्जी वो
कर सकते हैं राइट
मैंने पिन कर दिया
ओके चलो तो बेसिकली 18 में से स्टार्ट हो
रही है तो जिसको करना है 17 तक कल तक कर
सकता है ल अभी भी टाइम है आपके पास सेम
ऑफर में
चलो ओके सर ट्राई हैक मी सब्सक्रिप्शन
फ्री में कैसे ले भाई आज तक तो मुझे भी
फ्री में नहीं मिली तो तुम्हे कहां से मिल
जाएगी सीधी बात है फ्री में नहीं मिलती है
ा के सब्सक्रिप्शन परचेस करने पड़ते हैं
कहीं कहीं आपको थोड़े कम में मिल जाएंगे
किसी किसी ऑफर प्राइस में व अलग बात है तो
बट वैसे परचेस ही करने पड़ते हैं ज्यादा
मैं यहां पे क्या
बोलूं सर एक बग फाइंड करने में कितना समय
लग सकता है टोटली आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है
कितना टाइम लगेगा आपकी क्या डेडिकेशन है
कितनी इवॉल्वमेंट है किस टाइप का स्कोप है
उसपे कमांड इंजेक्शन का रिपोर्ट कैसे
बनाना है जैसे बाकी रिपोर्ट्स बनाते हैं
वैसे ही कमांड इंजेक्शन का भी रिपोर्ट
बनाना है बस सिंपल सा फंडा है क्या बात है
यार 7 8 लोग आ चुके हैं अरे लाइक ठोक दो
लाइक तो ठोको बस 78 लोग आ चुके हैं देखो अ
ये डाउट सेशन में 78 लोग आना बड़ी बात है
भाई ग्रेट बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत सारे क्वेश्चंस है भाई कुछ
क्वेश्चन स्किप हो जा रहे हैं तो माफ
कीजिएगा भाई उसके
लिए और क्वेश्चन ले लेते हैं यहां पे लव
फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर
लव फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रो सब बक राउड में एक प्रोग्राम है लॉग
फाइल्स में था क्या लॉग फाइल्स में डोमेन
का p5 बता दिया हाउ टू मेक p3 ये अरे तो
आप देखो यही तो बात
है अब तुम्हारा मान लो कोई लेबिलिटी मिला
तुम्हें और उसको p5 बता दिया किसी सामने
वाले ने प्लेटफॉर्म ने अब यह 100% जरूरी
नहीं है कि तुम p5 को p3 p2 p1 में कर ही
लोगे कन्वर्ट वो एक्चुअल में p5 भी हो
सकता है बट हां अगर चेनिंग पॉसिबल है
चेनिंग कर पा रहे हो तो ट्राई करना चाहिए
अब देखो कि जो तुमने फाइंड किया है उसको
हम और ज्यादा एक्सप्लोइटेबल कैसे बना सकते
हैं एक्चुअल में बना भी सकते हैं कि नहीं
और इससे लिंक्ड करके कुछ और क्रिटिकल हो
सकता है कि नहीं हो सकता अगर हो सकता है
तो ठीक है नहीं तो छोड़ दो नहीं तो p5 ही
रहेगा वो सिंपल एज दैट ठीक
है हां लॉग फाइल मिला था बट लॉग फाइल में
क्या है उस परे डिपेंड करता है लॉग फाइल
के अंदर एंट्रीज क्या है लॉग फाइल्स में
क्या डेटा कंटेन करता है उस परे डिपेंड
करता है डेटा इंपैक्टफुल नहीं होगी वो p5
या इंफॉर्मेशन ही होगी अगर इंपैक्टफुल कुछ
है उसके अंदर तभी वो कुछ कंसीडरेबल है या
कोई क्रिटिकल लेबिलिटी में कंसीडर होगा
अदर वाइज नहीं होगी वो ठीक
है सर जी रिस्प आई एम आस्किंग क्या
आस्किंग भाई आस्किंग भाई क्या आस्किंग जरा
ये तो बताओ क्या आस्किंग देखते हैं अ टेल
मी सर योर अप्रोच ऑफ गेटिंग टारगेट एंड
हाउ मच मोर आई कैन फ्लेक्स नॉर्मल एक्सेस
टू सो इंपैक्ट सरक आम आई एम फाइंडिंग मोर
सर जी क्या पूछ रहे हो भाई ये मेरे को समझ
नहीं आया क्वेश्चन फिर भी मैं जवाब दे
देता हूं इसका जवाब है कि आप पूरी वीडियोस
देखिए पूरा पूरा स्टार्टिंग से समझ में आ
जाएगा मैंने पहले ही बताया हुआ है कि कैसे
अप्रोच करना है टारगेट को ये मैंने बहुत
स्टार्टिंग के क्लासेस में बताया हुए है
तो डे वन से स्टार्ट कीजिए और एकदम एक एक
डिटो प उसको देखिए स्किप मत कीजिए ठीक
है नेक्स्ट लाइव सेशन कब होगा नेक्स्ट
क्लास कब होगा यह पूछो लाइव सेशन तो ही
रहा है नेक्स्ट लाइव सेशन कल मतलब एक या
दो दिन के अंदर में हो जाएगी क्योंकि आज
तो डाउट सेशन ले लिया तो टॉपिक वाली क्लास
बहुत जल्दी होगी नेक्स्ट
वाली डेनिक्स पे डि फोनिक्स पे अ एथिकल
हैकिंग कोर्स अवेलेबल है क्या नहीं भाई
कोई अन एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स नहीं
है सर लॉग में क्या सेंसिटिव हो सकता है
लॉग में तो बहुत सारी चीज सेंसिटिव हो
सकती है डेटाबेस हो सकता है कंप्लीट
कंप्लीट डेटाबेस हो सकता है पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है जो नहीं होनी चाहिए
लीक्ड बहुत सारी चीज हो सकती है कंपनी का
कोई क्रिटिकल डाटा हो सकता है यह सारी चीज
हो सकती
है राइट
चलो वन ऑफ द सिंसियर टीचर विथ ज
स्टूडेंट्स सैयद अली काजमी धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद भाई सैयद अली धन्यवाद
ब्रदर स रिकन को स्टार्ट से एंड तक
स्टेप्स बता दो अब देखो भाई यह बबू चक जी
पूछ रहे रिकन का स्टेप्स बताऊ अब मैं
इसमें क्या करू बताओ अब खुद नहीं देखोगे
क्लियर तो फिर कैसे मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
राइट वीडियोज नहीं देखे इसका मतलब तुमने
स्टार्टिंग के एज सिंपल एज दैट स्टार्टिंग
के वीडियोस देखते तो बंद आ जाता स बक
बाउंट में इंटर्नशिप कैसे ले टेंशन मत लो
इंटर्नशिप वर्क बाउंटीज के अंदर मैं खुद
आप लोगों की कराऊंगा और मैं आपसे इतना जो
बोलता हूं कि कंसंट्रेट करो रेगुलर रहो
लाइव में मेरे साथ फ्लो में चलने की कोशिश
करो पहले के लाइव छूटे उसको जल्दी से
कंप्लीट करो न्यू लाइव क्लासेस जो आती हैं
अब टॉपिक्स वाइज आती है तो आप प्रीवियस ना
भी हुआ कंप्लीट तो भी न्यू वाले लाइव
क्लासेस को देख सकते हो तो बहुत बहुत जल्द
हो सकता है बहुत जल्द का मतलब इन द सेंस
कि अभी तो कुछ टाइम है एक महीना कम से कम
हम इंटर्नशिप वग बाउंटीज पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग की लेकर आएंगे सभी स्टूडेंट्स
एंड प्रोफेशनल्स के लिए भी वो एक बहुत ही
बहुत ही इंटेंस
इंटर्नशिप आपका होगा एंड ऐसा इंटर्नशिप
जहां आपको कुछ प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम्स दिए
जाएंगे
कुछ ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स जहां पर सिर्फ आप हंट
कर रहे होंगे और कुछ सिलेक्टेड ग्रुप ऑफ
हैकर्स यानी बग बाउंट हंटर्स यानी कि कुछ
ही लोग उस पर हंट कर रहे होंगे ह ऐसे नहीं
होंगे कि वहां दो 3300 हंटर्स पड़े हुए
हैं एंड आपसे वह इंटर्नशिप के अंदर में
बहुत सारी चीजें हैं वह कराई जाएंगी
एंड पॉसिबली आपको स्टाइप एट भी दिया जाएगा
आई एम नॉट सेइंग अभी कुछ भी ज्यादा इसके
ऊपर में क्योंकि पूरी डिटेल अनाउंसमेंट
वगर आएगी सारी डिटेल डिटेल मैं आपको
बताऊंगा बट इतना मान के चलो यू विल गेट
इंटर्नशिप आप ऑनलाइन उसको कर पाओगे एंड वो
इंटर्नशिप आप अपने रिज्यूमे में बड़े
प्राउडली शो कर पाओगे कि मैंने भाई ये काम
किया है पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के अंदर एज अ
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट एट डिफर निक्स साइबर
सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेट लिमिटेड कंपनी जो कि
गवर्नमेंट ऑफ इंडिया अप्रूव्ड कंपनी है
आल्सो सर्टिफाइड कंपनी है एंड इसकी
सर्टिफिकेट्स इसकी नॉलेज इसके स्किल्स
इंडिया ही में नहीं इंडिया के बाहर दुनिया
के कोने-कोने में वैली है कोई इसको
इनवैलिड नहीं कर सकता किसी की हिम्मत नहीं
है एज सिंपल एज दैट ठीक है
भैया बस इतना ही
है तो हां जी बिल्कुल बिल्कुल शमीम
बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल इंटर्नशिप अपॉर्चुनिटी जो होगी बग
बाउंटीज में उसमें आपको स्टाइप एें भी मिल
सकती है जरूरी नहीं कि सबको स्टाइप एंड
मिले लेकिन कुछ सिलेक्टेड स्टूडेंट्स को
स्टाइप एंड मिलेगी एंड दैट स्टाइप एंड
मतलब लिटरली दैट स्टाइप एंड कैन बी रेंज
फ्रॉम ₹ पर मंथ टू 00 पर मंथ एट
स्टार्टिंग मतलब अभी जो स्टाइपेंड जो भी
मिलेगा आपको 000 से 00 तक का आपको
स्टाइपेंड मिल जाएगा इसका एक पूरा प्रोसेस
होगा उस प्रोसेस को फॉलो करना पड़ेगा आपको
एंड देन आप उस इंटर्नशिप प्रोग्राम का
हिस्सा बन पाएंगे ऐसा नहीं है कि कोई भी
आएगा और सभी उसका इंटर्नशिप का हिस्सा बन
जाएंगे नॉट पॉसिबल ठीक है एक प्रोसेस होगा
उस प्रोसेस के तहत आप आइएगा एंड देन यू
विल बी एलिजिबल फॉर इंटर्नशिप अगर आपने उस
प्रोसेस को क्लियर कर लिया तो तो इसमें
वही क्लियर कर पाएंगे जो मेरी जो अभी
क्लासेस चल रही है बग बाउंटीज को उसको
प्रॉपर्ली देखते हैं समझते हैं सीखते हैं
नोट्स बनाते हैं रिवाइज करते हैं
प्रैक्टिस करते हैं हंट करते हैं फिर इसको
रिपीट करते हैं वो पक्का से उस इंटर्नशिप
राउंड को क्लियर कर लेंगे इंटर्नशिप का
पार्ट बन जाएंगे ठीक है ट्स इट
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके चलिए और भी क्वेश्चंस लेते
हैं सर मैं आपको एक सरप्राइज देने वाला
हूं मेरा नाम विकास मौर्य याद कर लो जकास
गेमर ओह क्या बात है जकास गेमर भाई क्या
सरप्राइज देने वाला यह तो बता दो थोड़ा सा
हिंट तो दो भाई क्या सरप्राइज है
अ विकाश मौर्य सरप्राइजेज तो मुझे काफी
अच्छे लगते हैं भाई सरप्राइज दोगे तो मजा
आ जाएगा मतलब मेरे लिए तो सबसे बड़ा अगर
सरप्राइज बोलो अभी तुम्हारी क्लासेस में
तो यह है कि तुम एक वैलिड बग फाइंड कर
लिया तुमने
दैट्ची मिलल गई या रिवॉर्ड मिल गया फिर तो
वो सोने पे सुहागा हो जाता है तो अगर कुछ
ऐसा सरप्राइज है तो भाई मुझे जरूर देना
बताना आई विल बी वेटिंग फॉर दैट थैंक यू
सो मच
वाह क्या बात है कॉलेज का वेबसाइट हैक कर
लिया क्यारे रे रे क्या बात है धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद चलो बहुत
बढ़िया सर आप रिप्लाई नहीं मिला क्या
रिप्लाई नहीं मिला भाई अरे कुछ क्वेश्चन
का भाई रिप्लाई जरूरी नहीं है कि मिल जाए
मतलब इन द सेंस की कुछ क्वेश्चन पीछे रह
जा रही है तो मेरे को फिर मैं स्क्रॉल कर
ही रहा हूं कुछ क्वेश्चन अगर पीछे है
तो मेरा गया क्वेश्चन ऊपर सर जी य आप देखो
ना एक बार
हैं ओके डीसी एपी का
[संगीत]
whatsapp2 टुनाइट ठीक है और 18 से आपकी
ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट हो रही है लिंक मैंने
ऑलरेडी पिन कर दिया है इस चैट में जिसको
भी ए पन टेस्टिंग में आना है फटाफट अभी भी
आ जाना क्योंकि 17 कल तक आप इनरोल कर सकते
हैं सेम ऑफर फी में ऑफर फी का हमने वो हटा
दिया लिमिट ओ मिट तो जो भी आएगा ऑफर फी
में इनरोल करेगा एज सिंपल एज दैट तो कल तक
आप आ सकते हो एंड हमारी सीट्स ऑफर वाली
ऑलरेडी फुल हो चुकी है ऐसा नहीं कि सीट्स
बची हुई है सीट्स फुल हो चुकी है बट फिर
भी तुम आ सकते हो क्योंकि हम कल तक इसको
अलाउ कर रहे हैं ठीक है बस दैट्ची थी 30
फुल हो चुकी है हमने उसको और एक्सटेंड कर
दिया एंड अब तुम एक्सटेंडेड पांच सीट प भी
आ सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
चलिए बग हंटिंग वर्सेस एप पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग व्हिच इज बेस्ट कोई बेस्ट नहीं
है भाई दोनों ही बेस्ट है याद रखिएगा बग
अब तुम पूछोगे कि वेब पन टेस्टिंग बेस्ट
है ए पेन टेस्टिंग बेस्ट है आओ पन
टेस्टिंग बेस्ट है कि एपीआई पन टेस्टिंग
बेस्ट है कुछ भी कोई बेस्ट नहीं है सब एक
से एक बढ़ के हैं और सभी जरूरी है सभी
बढ़िया है सभी की नॉलेज तुम्हें होनी
चाहिए मेरे अकॉर्डिंग ठीक
है सर क्या एपीआई टेस्टिंग में बहुत स्कोप
है हां जी बहुत स्कोप इसलिए क्योंकि वहां
लोग कम है भाई इसलिए स्कोप बहुत है करेक्ट
फी कितनी है जाओ डिटेल्स चेक करो ना ऊपर
में पिंड लिंक है वेब उसपे जाओ और डिटेल
चेक करो उसमें सारी फी डिटेल सब कुछ है
ओरिजिनल फी 14000 डिस्काउंटेड फी फ्लैट
अभी 7000 का जिसको टू टाइम्स में आपको
करना है
दैट्ची लिंकन पर डालो यार टैग मारो यार
कैसे पता चलेगा मतलब या
मैं लेता हूं ऐसे ही नहीं ले रहा मैं
इसमें भी मेहनत लगती है ठीक है रिसर्च
लगता है बहुत कुछ होता है ठीक है अब कुछ
ऐसी वलने बिलिटी भी है जो मैं आपको आने
वाले टाइम में बताऊंगा वोन वनबिल के बारे
में मैंने ज्यादा नहीं पढ़ा हुआ है
इनफैक्ट उसको मैंने हंट पे हंट हंटिंग में
यूज ही नहीं किया है क्योंकि जरूरी नहीं
है सारे वलने बिलिटी आप हंट करो कुछ ऐसे
कुछ-कुछ वनबिल हैं जो शायद आपने भी नहीं
पढ़े होंगे मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम में मेरे को
ऐसा लग रहा है ज्यादातर लोग उसको हंट डाउन
नहीं करते हैं तो ऐसी वलने बिटीज भी मैं
आपको बताऊंगा इनफैक्ट इसी क्लास में
बताऊंगा तो उसके लिए रिसर्च करके ही
बताऊंगा और आपको एक प्रॉपर वे में ऐसा
बताऊंगा कि आप फिर जिंदगी में कभी भूलोगे
नहीं और दूसरों को पढ़ा पाओगे दूसरों को
सिखा पाओगे इस टाइप से तो ऐसी चीजें होती
है जरूरी नहीं हमें सब कुछ आता हो भाई
नहीं जरूरी है आपको भी पूरी आती है जरूरी
नहीं है किसी को भी पूरी नहीं आती कुछ भी
नहीं आता किसी को पूरा अगर कोई बोल रहा है
कि भाई आम आई एम बेस्ट एट इट आई एम मास्टर
ऑफ इट ये सब ये सब सब फालतू गिरी है भाई
कुछ ये सब बकवास की बातें हैं सब कहने की
बातें हैं बेवकूफ बनाने की बातें हैं कैसे
कोई जान जाएगा हर कोई यार हर कोई हर चीज
कैसे पता चल जाएगा इंपॉसिबल है उसके लिए
तो तुम पढ़ते रहो ना अपडेट रख सकते हो खुद
को यह बात कह सकते हो कि आई हैव बीन
रेगुलरली रेगुलरली अपडेटिंग माइसेल्फ टू
दिस पर्टिकुलर टेक्नोलॉजी और टू दिस
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन और टू दि स्पेसिफिक डोमेन
पार्ट ऑफ डोमेन बट ये नहीं कि मैं मास्टर
हो गया हूं मेरे अलावा किसी को कुछ आता
नहीं है मैं मैं ही सब कुछ जानता हूं दिस
इज नॉट
गुड ठीक है
ज्यादा से ज्यादा सब डोमेन कैसे ढूंढे बता
सकते हैं भैया अरे भाई यार सब डोमेन कैसे
ढूंढे पूछ रहा है यह साइबर क्राइम अपडेट्स
इसको कोई बताओ कि सब डोमेन कैसे ढूंढे
जाते हैं यह मैंने बताया है कि नहीं बताया
भाई ऐसे करोगे तो कैसे चलेगा बताओ मुझे
मतलब एक तो इतना टाइम देके मैं तुम्हारी
क्लासेस लेता हूं फ्री में इतना इतना टाइम
टाइम का दो दो घंटे की क्लासेस में ले
लेता हूं और तुम 30 32 क्लासेस होने के
बाद पूछ र सब डोमेन कैसे फाइंड करते हैं
हे भगवान भाई पूरा बता बताया हुआ है यार
स्टार्टिंग के वीडियोस देखो डे वन से देखो
ना सारे टॉपिक्स डील किए हुए हैं मैंने
सारी चीजें बताई है अब ऐसे करोगे कैसे काम
चलेगा सर एक न्यू को न्यू कोर्स बनाओ वेब
पेन टेस्टिंग के ऊपर अब देखो ये मुशर्रफ
मुशर्रफ जी को देखिए क्या बोल रहे हैं
न्यू कोर्स बनाओ वेब पन टेस्टिंग के ऊपर
क्या यार बच्चों वाली बातें करते हो तुम
लोग कुछ भी बोल देते हो मतलब चल रहा है
ऑलरेडी कोर्स भाई ऑलरेडी बेस्ट कोर्स चल
रहा है लाइव चल रहा है अब क्या चाहिए न्यू
कोर्स क्या चाहिए
ओके सर मेरा क्वेश्चन यह है कि प्रैक्टिस
को और बेहतर कैसे करूं सर को सर कोई टिप्स
बता दीजिए अब मैं आपको एक टिप देता हूं
बहुत लोगों का ना प्रोका लाइक प्रो
कास्टिन का एक एक बीमारी होता है ठीक है
प्रोकट बहुत ज्यादा करते हैं लोग मतलब
इसका मतलब होता है टालना प्रो कास्टिन का
मतलब टालना होता है एक तरह से चीजों को
टालते हैं ठीक है जैसे मान लो उनको शाम को
कोई क्लास करनी है शाम को कोई टॉपिक पढ़ना
है शाम हो गई अरे थोड़ा अच्छा अभी रुक
जाते हैं यार थोड़ी देर बाद पढ़ लेंगे फिर
थोड़ी देर बाद अरे दो एक घंटे बात कर अरे
थोड़ा भी वेट कर लेते थोड़ा आराम कर लेते
फिर कर लेंगे अच्छा रात को ही करेंगे अब
छोड़ो अरे रात को अब तो हो गई खाना होना
खाके यार अब मन नहीं कर रहा यार अब कल
करेंगे ना कल एकदम फ्रेश होके उठेंगे कल
एकदम फ्रेश माइंड से करेंगे तो इस तरह की
आदतें होती है इस तरह की आदतें आपको दूर
जब तक नहीं होंगी ना आपकी या दूर नहीं कर
पाओगे तब तक बहुत कुछ नहीं कर पाओगे सच यह
सच्चाई है आपको ना अपने कंफर्ट जोन से
बाहर आना है कंफर्ट जोन में रहो बिल्कुल
रहो कंफर्ट जोन में रहना भी माइंड को
हेल्दी रखने के लिए काफी जरूरी है लेकिन
कंफर्ट जोन में ही रहे मत रह जाओ मेरे
कहने का सेंस ये है कंफर्ट जोन से बाहर भी
निकलना है एक टाइम फिक्स करो कंफर्ट जोन
के लिए अपने कि आज मैं इतने टाइम से इतने
टाइम तक रिलैक्स करूंगा और जब रिलैक्स
करूंगा तो उस टाइम में कुछ नहीं करूंगा इन
द सेंस कि मैं क्या बोल रहा हूं कि मैं
मैं भी देखो मैं भी जो अप्लाई करता हूं
वही बता रहा हूं मैं कुछ आपको अलग से नहीं
बता रहा मैं भी जब मेरा रिलैक्स का टाइम
होता है ना लिटरली तो मैं मोबाइल को साइड
कर देता हूं ठीक है मोबाइल साइड कर दिया
उसको साइलेंट पे कर दिया अब मैं अपना
रिलैक्स में जो करना है कर रहा हूं
रिलैक्स कर रहा हूं लेटा हूं थोड़ा कुछ
वैसे ही कुछ कोई कोई कोई किताब निकाल ली
ऐसे ही थोड़ा पढ़ रहा हूं ऐसे कुछ कुछ कुछ
कुछ चीजें कर रहा हूं ठीक है वो रिलैक्स
मेंट पीरियड हो गया उसमें मैं कोई ऐसा काम
नहीं करता जिसमें दिमाग प ज्यादा जोर देना
पड़े जिसमें एक्चुअल में वो कुछ
एग्जीक्यूशन हो रही हो किसी चीज की नहीं
नॉर्मल सा टाइम समय अगर कोई फोन भी आ रहा
है इग्नोर मैसेज आ रहा है
इग्नोर हां आपका अगर ऐसा ऐसा ही दिमाग है
तो ठीक है फिर जब काम करना है तो उस टाइम
में भी जैसे आप अपने रिलैक्सेशन के टाइम
में इग्नोर कर रहे हो ना उसी टाइम पे आप
अपने फोन को उस टाइम में जब आप काम कर रहे
हो तब भी वैसे इग्नोर करो जैसे उस टाइम कर
रहे थे रिलैक्सेशन के टाइम ऑटोमेटिक
प्रोडक्टिविटी आपकी बढ़ेगी और हर दिन एक
डिसाइड करो गोल कि आज मुझे आज मुझे दिन भर
के दिन भर में 10 घंटे यह काम 10 घंटे का
काम प्रोडक्टिव करना है उसमें दो घंटे ये
करने दो घंटे ये करने दो घंटे ये ऐसे करके
डिवाइड करो और उसके अकॉर्डिंग काम
पोमोडोरो टेक्निक्स ये सब तुम्हें पता
होगा तुम टेक्निक फॉलो करो पोमोडोरो या ना
करो तुम्हारी अपनी चॉइस है पर्सनल सब लोग
नहीं कर पाते उस चीज को ठीक है बट अपना
खुद का टेक्निक बनाओ कि दो घंटे काम किया
और उसमें आधे घंटे के लिए ब्रेक ले लिया
ऐसे करो दो घंटे काम किया आधे घंटे का
ब्रेक ले लिया प्रोडक्टिविटी बढ़ जाएगी
मजा भी आएगा ठीक
है ये चीज समझो सर सर प्लीज रिप्लाई व्हाट
इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन प्रीमियम कोर्सेस अ
एंड फ्री कोर्सेस क्या डिफरेंस है मतलब
मैंने समझा नहीं देखो अगर तुम लोग ये पूछ
रहे हो कि हां इसमें और बाकी वो पे पेड
में क्या अंतर है आपकी जो ये क्लासेस चलती
हैं बग बाउंटीज के इस क्लासेस को आप फॉलो
करेंगे तो आप बिल्कुल जीरो है ना तो आप
जीरो से प्रो लेवल तक कर सकते हैं ठीक है
आप बेसिक लेवल से बिगनर लेवल से
इंटरमीडिएट टॉप इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक जा
सकते हैं बिल्कुल जा सकते हैं एंड आप
बेसिकली प्रो लेवल की भी चीजें अटेंड कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि आपको उसमें एक्सप्लोर
थोड़ा करना पड़ेगा अब बिना एक्सप्लोर किए
तो आप बिगनर लेवल पे ही रह जाइएगा
सीधा-सीधा बात है आप बिना एक्सप्लोर किए
अगर इस पूरी बग बाउटी की प्लेलिस्ट को
फॉलो करते हैं तो आप कुछ नहीं कर पाएंगे
आपको खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर करना है ठीक है
अब आपको मेरे भरोसे ऐसे नहीं बैठना है कि
अरे सर सर देखो आपने तो सब डोमेन फाइंड
करना बताया स्क्रीनशॉटिंग बताई डायरेक्टरी
बड फोर्सिंग बताई अब सर आप मेरे घर पर आओ
मेरे लिए एक रिपोर्ट राइट करो और अगर
मैंने एक पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्टरी डायरेक्टरी
बट फोर्सिंग में कोई एक एंड पॉइंट खोजा है
तो उसके अंदर की क्रिटिकल चीजें मुझे
फाइंड करके बताओ या तो फिर अगर उसके अंदर
कोई क्रिटिकल चीज नहीं मिली मुझे नॉर्मल
जेनरिक चीज मिली है तो अब क्रिटिकल कैसे
मिलेगा वह मुझे बताओ क्रिटिकल मिल भी गया
मैंने रिपोर्ट किया तो मेरा रिपोर्ट करने
का तरीका सही नहीं था इसलिए वह थोड़ा लेस
क्रिटिकल कैटेगरी में चला गया तो उसका
तरीका बताओ या और भी कोई टूल सेट्स हैं और
भी कोई मेथड है वह बताओ तो यह काम मैं
नहीं करूंगा कभी नहीं करूंगा मैं आपको
सिर्फ गाइड करूंगा आपको कुछ मेथड सिखाऊंगा
कैसे करना है बाकी के चीजें आपको
एक्सप्लोर करके खुद ही करनी है तभी उसमें
आप ज्यादा चीजें सीखेंगे एंड ज्यादा अच्छे
से आगे बढ़ेंगे ज्यादा फास्ट आपका ग्रोथ
होगा इतना समझ के रखो ठीक है
सर मोहल्ले मुझे तीन पी फ मिले हैं एक
[संगीत]
विशाल सिंह ऊपर जो लिंक दिया गया है ना
ऊपर विशाल . कडीसी उस पर जाइए उसमें उसमें
जाइएगा उस परे तो आप जब पेमेंट वाले ऑप्शन
पर जाइएगा ना नरोल नाउ प तो वहां पर नीचे
जाइएगा रेजर पे के पेज प कांटेक्ट का आपको
ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा हमारा फोन नंबर मिल जाएगा
ठीक है वैसे मैं फोन नंबर दे देता हूं
हमारा जो नंबर
है हमारा जो नंबर है वह दे देता हूं मैं
आप इस पर कांटेक्ट कर सकते हैं चैट में दे
दिया
मैंने सर आपका मेन अप्रोच टारगेट पर क्या
होता है विदाउट रिकॉन सबसे पहली बात मैं
आपको ललित मैं एक चीज क्लियर बताता हूं
मोस्ट ऑफ द केसेस में मैं रिकॉर्न ही करता
हूं सबसे पहले बहुत ऐसी कम केसेस होते हैं
जहां मैं रिकॉर्न मतलब रिकॉर्न से पहले
कुछ कर कर रहा हूं या कुछ ऐसा किया हो ठीक
है बट बहुत मैक्सिमम अप्रोच मेरे रिकॉर्न
के पहले होते हैं उसके बाद कोई और चीज आती
है अगर मैं रिकॉर्न नहीं कर रहा हूं बाय
चांस तो मैं सबसे पहले लो हैंगिंग के लिए
ही जाता हूं एंड उसमें भी कुछ छोटी-छोटी
चीजें आपको लेनी है देखनी है ठीक है ना
लाइक ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल वगैरह आप
थोड़ा देखो उस परे ट्राई करो वो चीजें
काफी जल्दी आपको मिल जाती है एक्सेसेस अ
सिंपल एक्सेसेस वगैरह आईडी आर वगैरह ट्राई
करो चीजें मिलने की इन चीजों को फाइंड
करने की ज्यादा लाइक चांसेस होते हैं
सीएसआरएफ वगर ट्राई करो ऐसे ही करो
रोबोट्स t एक्टी वाली चीजें एक बार ट्राई
करो शान का यूज करो शान सर्च क्वेरीज सर्च
फिल्टर्स का यूज करो उसमें काफी कुछ मिल
जाएंगी
प थोड़ा हाथ आजमाओ वहां पर काफी कुछ मिल
जाएगा तो इन सब चीजों को यूज करो ठीक है
जब तक आप हार्डकोर किसी पर्टिकुलर उस पर
नहीं आ जाते
ओके
ओके तो रिकन इंपोर्टेंट है सर रिकन तो अरे
यार रिकन कैसे इंपोर्टेंट नहीं है भाई
रिकन इंपोर्टेंट नहीं बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है
क्या बात कर रहे हो तुम न इ वेरी मच
इंपोर्टेंट सर पी फ बग कनी ने फिक्स नहीं
किया तो बग रिपोर्ट डिस्क्लोज करूं या
नहीं करूं वो तो फिक्स करोगे तभी फिक्स
करने के बाद ही डिस्क्लोज होगा तुम्हारा
करके देखो एक बार क्या क्वेश्चन है भाई
नौसिखिया जी क्या क्वेश्चन है
गुरुदेव कैन यू रेस्पों हाउ मच मोर
इंपैक्ट आई कैन शो विथ नॉर्मल एक्सेसेस
एंड आई एम फेसिंग एरर ऑन बायपासिंग डब्लू
एफ योर लिस्ट इज नॉट वर्किंग सर जी यही तो
बात है अब देखो यहां एक बढ़िया एग्जांपल
मेरे को मिला है मैं सबको ये चीज बता देता
हूं ठीक है नौसिखिया जी का क्वेश्चन है कि
इनको एक एक्सेसेस मिला है वेफ बायपास ये
नहीं कर पा रहे हैं मतलब नहीं कर पा रहे
किसी और उसमें ट्राई करना है यह बोल रहे
है कि मेरी लिस्ट वर्क नहीं कर रही है यह
मैंने कब बोला आपको कि मेरी लिस्ट हर जगह
काम करेगी मैंने तो आपको एक लिस्ट दिया है
पेलोड्स का बस ये नहीं बोला कि हर जगह काम
करेगा वो एक तरीका है आपको बताने का लिस्ट
आपको दिया एक पेलोड दिया अब आपको अपना
पेलोड खुद ही वहां पर बेसिकली टारगेट के
अकॉर्डिंग अपना पेलो जनरेट करना है आपको
अपना पेलोड क्राफ्ट करना है एंड वो आपको
खुद करना है वफ के अकॉर्डिंग
डिंग पलट को क्राफ्ट करो और फिर उसको यूज
करो सिर्फ मेरा पेलोड यूज कर लोगे तो कहां
से चलेगा
भाई साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन कब
स्टार्ट होगा स बहुत जल्दी स्टार्ट होगा
उसका बैच क्योंकि कुछ मल्टीपल बैचेज आ रहे
थे तो डिले हो रहा है थोड़ा सा बट जल्दी
हम स्टार्ट करेंगे ठीक है एंड जल्दी आपके
सामने वह ट्रेनिंग
होगी अरे क्लाउड फ्लेयर के भी व की मैं
बात कर रहा हूं क्लाउड फ्लेर की व की बात
कर रहा हूं सार व बायपास पलट तुम्ह
मिलेंगे उनको ट्राई करो एक बार अगर खुद से
क्राफ्ट नहीं कर पाओगे तो एक बार जस्ट गिव
इट अ
ट्राई
हा बिल्कुल बिल्कुल एक वीडियो रिपोर्ट
राइटिंग पर बिल्कुल आएगी एक वीडियो
रिपोर्ट राइटिंग पर बिल्कुल आएगी हा और
करो ट्राई मारो ट्राई मारो आ जाएगा भाई
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है और क्वेश्चन सुपर में
कुछ छूटे
क्या
अ सर सर सर इट्स द क्या सर क्या बोल रहे
हो इट्स डी भाई बताओ कोई क्वेश्चन है
आपका इट्स डी आरसी टेक कैसे हो सर मैं
बढ़िया दिव्यांश मिश्रा एकदम छका चकाचक
तुम
बताओ अपलोड डिटेल वीडियो ऑफ ईच लेबिलिटी
फ्रॉम टॉप 10 मेक श्यर टू कवर ऑल द पॉसिबल
वेज टू डिस्कवर बट सर प्लीज
डोंट सजेस्ट टू चेक टी एचएम फॉर इट अरे टी
एचएम चेक तो करो बिल्कुल करो टी एचएम तो
चेक करना है भाई तुम सोचोगे नहीं करो तो
फिर यह गलत बात है लेकिन मैं भी लेकर आ ही
रहा हूं यार ओ टॉप 10 के काफी सारी
लेबिलिटी मैंने कवर किए हैं जाके डे व वन
से देखो स्टार्ट करो देखना बहुत सारी वटी
कवर किए है बहुत सारी बचे हुए वो भी कवर
करूंगा टेंशन नहीं लेनी उसकी ठीक है इट
विल बी
कवर्ड
और चलो और
तो नहीं है नीचे क्वेश्चन लेते
हैं आई वांट टू स्टार्ट एथिकल हैकिंग एनी
टिप्स टिप्स तो मैंने वैसे बहुत सारे दिए
हुए हैं ऑलरेडी आप लोगों कोल हैकिंग के
एकदम बेसिक से स्टार्ट कीजिए अपना कोर
स्ट्रांग कीजिए जितना कोर आपका स्ट्रांग
होगा उतना आपके लिए
बेनिफिट रहेगा बेनिफिशियल होगा वो चीज ठीक
है एंड वेब पन टेस्टिंग वगैरह में या या
पेट्रस टेस्टिंग में जाना है तो फिर हमारे
पास उसकी कंटेंट की कमी नहीं है हमारे पास
पूरे रिसोर्सेस उसको फॉलो कीजिए ठीक है या
किसी और डोमेन में जाना है तो उस
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन के रिसोर्सेस को फॉलो अप
कीजिए मेंटर कौन होगा साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन का मैं पैसे कलेक्ट कर रहा
हूं मेंटर ऑलरेडी हमारा ऑलरेडी फिक्स है
साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन का धीरज
बारबार एक ही क्वेश्चन पूछोगे कैसे काम
चलेगा मैंने पहले ही बोला था कि हम
डायरेक्ट अनाउंसमेंट में ही क्लोज करेंगे
ठीक है तो उसकी टेंशन मत लो मेंटर जो है
आपके बहुत नॉलेजेबल है ऑलरेडी एंड ऑलरेडी
ही इज वर्किंग विद साइबर सेल एंड ऑल तो अब
मेंटर का नाम एस से शुरू होता है बताओ
इतना बता दिया अब इससे ज्यादा नहीं
बताऊंगा ठीक
है अब तो खुश हो धीरज कि अभी भी दिक्कत
है सर आप क्वेश्चन पूछो अभी हां बिल्कुल
वही तो बात
है सर मेरी एग्जाम्स हैं कुछ टिप्स बताओ
फोकस्ड स्टडी के लिए अब देखो यार इसका एक
बहुत ही अच्छा टिप देता हूं आपका एग्जाम
है अगर आपको एग्जाम में अच्छा करना है
बेस्ट करना है अच्छा परफॉर्म करना है
अच्छे रिजल्ट्स लाने हैं तो कोई टिप की
जरूरत नहीं है तो आप फिर खुद उसी के लिए
पढ़ोगे ना उस अच्छे मार्क्स के लिए अच्छे
रिजल्ट के लिए आपको अगर मोटिवेशन की जरूरत
पड़ रही है फोकस को जबरदस्ती करवाने की
पड़ रही है मतलब कहीं ना कहीं लैक ऑफ वो
जो लैकिंग जो है ना ना लैकिंग वो है आपके
अंदर कहीं ना कहीं तो उसको हटाना पड़ेगा
और वो हटाओ ग आप ही कैसे हटाओ ग यह सोच के
कि भैया मुझे आज के टाइम में जब मेरे
एग्जाम्स हैं अगर मैं एग्जाम्स में अच्छा
नहीं कर पाया तो बस इतना सोच लो कि चार
लोग क्या कहेंगे बस इतना काफी है तुम्हारे
मोटिवेशन के लिए चार लोग आसपास वाले
सोसाइटी वाले क्या कहेंगे नेबर्स क्या
बोलेंगे पेरेंट्स को लोग क्या बोलेंगे अरे
आपका बेटा तो क्याय इतने मार्क्स ला अरे
हमारा बच्चा देखो इसी से तो मोटिवेशन आती
है भाई इससे अच्छे-अच्छे को मोटिवेशन आ
जाती है यह सोचो चार लोग क्या कहेंगे बस
यह चीज है ठीक है और अच्छी अच्छी नौकरी
नहीं मिलेगी तो तो अच्छी बहुत कुछ नहीं
मिलेगी सोच लो फिर समझ रहे हो ना अच्छी
नौकरी नहीं मिलेगी तो बहुत कुछ अच्छी नहीं
मिलेगी अच्छी नौकरी कैसे मिलती है अच्छी
पढ़ाई से अच्छी पढ़ाई कब होती है जब अच्छे
मार्क्स आते हैं तो मतलब मन भी लगता है
अच्छी पढ़ाई करते हो अच्छे कॉलेजेस में
जाओ
तो उसके लिए तो पढ़ना पड़ेगा
भाई है
ना एसकल इंजेक्शन की डिटेल वीडियो कब आ
रही है एल इंजेक्शन की क्लास आएगी यार
बहुत अब बहुत जल्द एसकल इंजेक्शन की ही
क्लास आएगी बहुत जल्द दे आऊंगा
पहली बाउंट कितने यूएसडीटी की मिली थी
50 ऐसी बातें क्यों पूछते हो जिस जिस
परे जिस पर मुझे थोड़ा सा मन नहीं करता
यार सच है कम है छोटा है बट सच है उसके भी
पहले जो मुझे बाउंटीज बाउंटीज करता हूं
मेरी मेरी पूरी लाइफ की लाइक मेरी जर्नी
की वो थे
000 जो मुझे मेरे कॉलेज यूनिवर्सिटी के
साइट से मिला हुआ था
वो जस्ट ऐसे ही था दैट वाज नॉट अ बाउंट या
समथिंग लाइक दैट मैंने उस परे मैं कभी ऐसा
कुछ डील भी मैं डिस्कस भी नहीं करता हूं
उस परे लेकिन स्टिल कोई पूछता है तो मैं
बता देता हूं कि हां वो मेरे लिए बहुत
क्लोज था मेरे लिए मेरे क्लोज टू माय
हार्ट इसलिए बिकॉज पहला वो पैसा जिस जो इस
चीज के लिए मिला था कि मैंने कुछ फाइंड
आउट किया हुआ था कुछ चीजें निकाली थी ट्स
वई तो 000 को ही मैं मानता हूं फर्स्ट वो
50 के भी पहले
सर 10000 निकाल लेते हो एक महीने के कहां
भाई हम तो गरीब लोग हैं 10000 कहां से
आएंगे 00 कहां से कमाएंगे
भाई बिल्कुल बिल्कुल इसलिए लड़की दर पढ़ाई
पास बिल्कुल
सही इट वाज वेरी इंस्पायरिंग बाय द वे
यूनिवर्सिटी का
सुपरस्टार थैंक यू धन्यवाद भाई हां थोड़ा
सा उस टाइम में मजा आया था उस टाइम में
थोड़ा क्या काफी मजा आया था जब तक कॉलेज
में था काफी मजा था मुझे सेकंड ईयर ऑनवर्ड
मुझे काफी मजे आए थे कॉलेज के टाइम में
व्हेन आई वर आई वाज इन कॉलेज मुझे कॉलेज
में फर्स्ट ईयर में बिल्कुल मजा नहीं आया
था फर्स्ट ईयर में मेरे लिए बस एक ही चीज
अच्छी थी और एक ही चीज मजेदार थी जो मुझे
मजा आता था वो यह था कि मुझे अनलिमिटेड
इंटरनेट का एक्सेस मिला था मेरे हॉस्टल
में क्योंकि मैं फर्स्ट ईयर हॉस्टल में
रहा था अ जब मैं कॉलेज में गया था तो वहां
कोई जानकार नहीं था राजस्थान में इनफैक्ट
जयपुर की मैं बात कर रहा हूं जानकार कोई
नहीं था और मैं मेरे को मेरे पापा छोड़ने
गए हुए थे एंड बहुत जल्दी-जल्दी में हुआ
था सब कुछ तो कोई भी नॉलेजेबल वहां पर
जानकार बंदा नहीं था ठीक है तो ऐसा हुआ कि
अब कहां पर रहे क्या करें तो कॉलेज से पता
चला कि एक हॉस्टल है हमारे से एसोसिएटेड
हॉस्टल है आप उसमें
ही बच्चे को डाल सकते हैं अच्छा हॉस्टल है
हालांकि वह अच्छा हॉस्टल नहीं था लेकिन
फिर भी कॉलेज से टाई अप था तो बोलेंगे ही
बेचारे तो हम उसी हॉस्टल में गए और हॉस्टल
में गए फिर वहां हॉस्टल में अनलिमिटेड
इंटरनेट था मुझे पता चला कि भाई वाईफाई है
और जितना यूज करना है कर लो वह चीज बस
मेरे को फर्स्ट ईयर में मेरी सबसे अच्छी
मेरे साथ हुई थी फिर सेकंड ईयर ऑनवर्ड जब
मैंने यूनिवर्सिटी की वेबसाइट हैक की थी
आई एम टॉकिंग अबाउट यूनिवर्सिटी वेबसाइट
नॉट कॉलेज वेबसाइट एंड द यूनिवर्सिटी
वेबसाइट वाज rtu.ac.in एंड जब मैंने उसको
कंप्रोमाइज किया था हैक किया बहुत सारी
चीजें वटी फाइंड की थी तब उसके बाद से जो
मेरी लाइफ चेंज हुई थी ड्यू टू सेवरल
थिंग्स दैट वाज द टर्निंग पॉइंट एंड तब
मुझ मुझे एक्चुअल में इसमें कुछ ज्यादा
मजा आया था उसके पहले से मैं हैकिंग की
चीजें करता था पढ़ता था मतलब सीखता रहता
था थोड़ी बहुत करता रहता था रिसर्च वगैरह
ई बुक्स काफी पढ़ता था तब मैं जाके बुक्स
खरीदने के पैसे नहीं होते थे तो ई ई बुक्स
से काम चलता
था
ओके सर i7 12650 है और आरटी 450 वाला
लैपटॉप सही है एफिशिएंट बग बांटी बिल्कुल
सही है भाई काफी है बट क्लॉक स्पीड क्या
है वो बता दो अनमोल महाजन आपकी लैपटॉप जो
है अभी आपके पास अनमोल महाजन उसकी बेस
क्लॉक स्पीड क्या है मुझे बताओ यह सब तो
ठीक
है आई वाच र वीडियो इट वास अ रिलेटेबल
वीडियो सिंस आई वास आल्सो आई वास आल्सो गट
अनलिमिटेड इंटरनेट इन पीजी हां बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट समीम
करेक्ट बीसीए होते ही पूरा फोकस बग हंटिंग
में करूंगा सर मैं एब्सलूट कर यू कैन कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
है सर वेब 3.0 में बग बाउंट का क्या
फ्यूचर है वेब 3.0 में बग बाउटी का
डिफरेंट फ्यूचर है इन द सेंस की वहां भी
चीज देखो यार ब्लॉकचेन में भी होती है
सिक्योरिटी ऑडिटिंग होती है ब्लॉकचेन में
भी हंटिंग होती है सब चीज होती है ठीक है
आप वहां पर भी करते हो हर एक जगह पर होती
है हां आपने कांट्रैक्ट कांट्रैक्ट्स का
नाम शायद सुना होगा कांट्रैक्ट सिक्योरिटी
का नाम सुना होगा या जो भी है नहीं भी
सुना है तो कोई बात नहीं सर्च कर लीजिएगा
तो हर जगह होती है अलग-अलग लेवल की होती
है वहां तो और भी ज्यादा पैसे आपको मिलते
बहुत ज्यादा पैसा होता है वहां प तो आप जा
सकते हो 2.0 के बाद कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है जब चाहे तब जा सकते हो सीखने की कोई वो
नहीं है यार कभी भी सीख सकते हो वीपीटी के
प्रोजेक्ट के बारे में बताइए इंटर्नशिप
में प्रोजेक्ट आएगा यार वो मैं इंटर्नशिप
में लेकर आऊंगा आपके लिए
सर एक्सप्लेन एपीआई पन टेस्टिंग एपीआई को
टेस्ट करना एपीआई पन टेस्टिंग होता है बस
एक लाइन का आंसर है बाकी डिटेल के लिए वेट
कीजिए वीडियो लाऊंगा मैं इसके
ऊपर सर आपके स्टूडेंट्स अन एथिकल काम कर
रहे हैं लाइक वेबसाइट को डिफेस करना या
लोग वलने बिलिटी को रिपोर्ट नहीं करते
डॉर्किंग वाले साइट्स पर अब यह तो मैं
क्या बोलू मैं कैसे रोकू मतलब कोई अगर गलत
यूज कर रहा है तो मैं कैसे उसको रोक सकता
हूं बताओ एक एक को इंडिविजुअली रोकना तो
पॉसिबल नहीं है राइट
सर आई हैव जस्ट स्टार्टेड योर लेक्चर कुड
यू टेल मी वयर आई कुड गेट बॉब क्रैक्ड
वर्जन कैफ शेक आप किसी भी लाइव वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइए वहां एक
वहां पे आपको बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस एंड आपको
जो टूल्स हैं उस सेक्शन में बब शूट मिल
जाएगा उसकी इंस्टॉलेशन ट्यूटोरियल भी मिल
जाएगी
ओके सर सीएस सीएसआरएफ पार्ट हंट करना
बेकार है क्योंकि बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स
में इंक्लूड नहीं है बहुत सारे
प्रोग्राम्स में इंक्लूड होता है और कुछ
प्रोग्राम्स में सीएसआरएफ का कुछ पार्ट
इंक्लूड नहीं करते हैं ले लॉग आउन लॉग आउट
लॉग इन सीस आरएफ वगैरह को कंसीडर नहीं
करते कई बार या पासवर्ड रिसेट की बात करें
तो बाकी जगहो पे तो मोस्टली एक्सेप्ट कर
ही लेते हैं मोस्ट ऑफ द केसेस
में सर आपके डीसीएसपी 3 का वेट कर रहा हूं
उसके बाद क्या एक्सपेक्ट कर सकता हूं मैं
डीसीएसपी थी एंड डीसीएसपी थी हो टू हो वन
हो जो भी है डीसीएसपी जो ट्रेनिंग है वो
अपने आप में बहुत ही धांसू लेवल का
ट्रेनिंग आप बोल सकते हो अलग लेवल की
ट्रेनिंग होती है उसमें कंप्लीट साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कंप्लीट नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
कंप्लीट पाइथन प्रोग्रामिंग ऑटोमेशन सब
चीज उसमें इंक्लूड है भाई और उसमें आपको
15 प्रोजेक्ट्स कराए जाते हैं 10 तो
जेनरिक प्रोजेक्ट्स मतलब ऐसे होते हैं और
कुछ मेजर प्रोजेक्ट्स भी कराए जाते हैं जो
आपके इंडस्ट्रियल इंटर्नशिप का पार्ट होता
है उसके जो कि डीसीएसपी में आपको कराया
जाता है डीसीएसपी में आपको इंडस्ट्रियल
इंटर्नशिप भी कराया जाता है नाउ अगेन सबको
वो इंटर्नशिप नहीं मिल सकती है हम
इंटर्नशिप जब कराते हैं किसी भी ट्रेनिंग
में तो यह ऑल ऑलरेडी अंडरस्टूड होना चाहि
आपको कि वो सबको नहीं मिलेगा 50 बच्चे हैं
तो 50 50 के 50 को इंडस्ट्रियल इंटर्नशिप
नहीं मिल पाएगी क्योंकि डिजर्विंग भी होने
चाहिए वो लोग तभी मिलेगी तो एक छोटा सा
टेस्ट होता है टेस्ट में अच्छे अगर आपके
मार्क्स आते हैं तो आप सिलेक्ट होते हैं
तो आपको इंटर्नशिप मिल जाएगी जैसे अभी
करंट डीसीएसपी में जो नंबर ऑफ स्टूडेंट्स
थे जिन्होंने जो इंडस्ट्रियल इंटर्नशिप के
पार्ट थे वो कम ही थे लाइक 10 के आसपास 10
या आठ आठ के आसपास उतने स्टूडेंट्स है तो
दे वेर डिजर्विंग इसलिए
सनिक्स प पर परचेस नहीं कर सकता हूम फ्रॉम
नेपाल ब्रदर र कोर्स वाला तो मैं हेल्प कर
दूंगा हमारे कांटेक्ट नंबर पर कांटेक्ट कर
लीजिएगा लेकिन बाकी में तो मुझे मैं कुछ
ज्यादा नहीं कर सकता क्या साइबर
सिक्योरिटी से बिलियन डॉलर बना सकते हैं
बिल्कुल बना सकते हैं भाई क्यों नहीं बना
सकते बिलियन डॉलर की यह करियर ही है भाई
मल्टी बिलियन मल्टी बिलियन डॉलर
साइब्र निक्स अपडेट कब आ रहा है जल्दी
आएगा भाई
जल्दी डार्क वेब एक्सेस के लिए फ्री
वीपीएन बता सकते हो क्या क्यों करनी अरे
भाई पल्लव एक बात बताओ तुम्हें डार्क वे
मान लो एक्सेस करना है तो तुम्हें फ्री
वीपीएन क्यों चाहिए टर यूज कर लो यार
सिंपल सा टर से बड़ा कुछ है क्या यह तो
बताओ टर से बड़ा कुछ है
राइट प्रोजेक्ट सर सजेस्ट सम प्रोजेक्ट
आइडियाज प्रोजेक्ट आइडियाज मतलब डिपेंड
करता है किस किस तरह का प्रोजेक्ट बनाना
चाहते हो मेरे ख्याल
से तुम डिटेक्शन सिस्टम डिटेक्शन सिस्टम
बना सक हो इंट या प्रिवेंशन कोई से भी बना
सकते हो आईडीएस आईपीएस वगैरह बना सकते हो
एक फायरल सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड प्रोजेक्ट
बना सकते हो इन द सेंस की अगर कोई फायर
वेल यूज हो रहा है किसी नेटवर्क के अंदर
में एंड फायर वेल का काम है प्रोटेक्ट
करना किसी भी नेटवर्क के अंदर में किसी भी
तरह के मेलिश पैकेट्स को बट मैं कहता हूं
कि अगर डायरेक्ट फायर वल फायरवॉल प अगर
कोई ऐसा कोई अटैक होता है रूट लेवल प अटैक
होता है फायरल के कोर लेवल फवल प अटैक
होता है उसको फिर कैसे सेव कर सकते हैं
उसको भी हम कुछ डिटेक्ट कर सकते हैं उसके
लिए अलग से बना सकते हो हालांकि ऐसी चीजें
हैं बट स्टिल यू कैन ट्राई ऑन कीलॉगर
वगैरह प जा सकते हो एक
सिक्योर यू कैन से कि
एक सीएनसी सर्वर बना सकते हो कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर के लिए जा सकते हो यू कैन
डेवलप योर कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर तो देर
आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट यू कैन डू
सर नासा बच्चों से कैसे हैक हो जाता है
नासा बच्चों से हैक होने का मतलब है कि
यार नासा में लेबिलिटी फाइंड कर लेते हैं
ना वो लोग कई लोग कर लेते हैं ना तो बच्चे
कैसे हो गए वो जो करते हैं व करते हैं
यार सर आईम नॉट एबल टू डाउनलोड वर्क
स्टेशन प्लीज कैन यू चेक वर्क स्टेशन के
ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट प जाओ भाई एंड वहां से
डाउनलोड करो ना क्या दिक्कत है आराम से हो
जाता है फिर क्या दिक्कत आ रही है
सर प्राइस टैंपरिंग में शो नहीं कर रहा है
कि वहां मैनिपुलेट कर सकते हैं प्राइस को
बब में नहीं दिखा दिखा रहा है वेब में
प्रॉब्लम है कि ब देखो हो सकता है आप क्रम
यूज कर रहे होंगे firefox.exe
10 से 15 के डॉलर निकाल सकते हैं 10 से 15
के डॉलर देखो निकालने को तो भाई नॉलेज के
दम पे बिगनर हो इंटरमीडिएट लेवल का हो कोई
एडवांस लेवल का हो कोई भी हो उससे फर्क
नहीं पड़ता बिगिनर्स भी आराम से इतने
डॉलर्स निकाल सकते हैं महीने के लेकिन
डिपेंड करता है कि वो सिर्फ डॉलर निकालने
के लिए कर रहे हैं हंट या हंटिंग के लिए
सिर्फ पैशन है हंट के लिए कर रहे हैं डॉलर
तो ऑटोमेटिक निकल जाएंगे आप हंटिंग करो बग
हंटिंग करो और उसके अलावा ना और कुछ मत मत
करो बग हंटिंग पर ध्यान दो बग हंटिंग करते
रहो डॉलर्स और पैसे और बाउंटीज ऑटोमेटिक
तुम्हारे बन जाएंगे महीने का 50 हज डॉलर
भी बन जाएगा टेंशन उसकी नहीं
लेनी सर बग बाउंट के लिए लेटेस्ट बुक कौन
सा है जिस फॉलो करूं वेब हैक 10 फॉलो कर
लो वेब एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स हैंड बुक फॉलो कर
लो अच्छी बुक्स है ये ऐसे बहुत सारे बुक्स
हैं ई बुक्स है अवेलेबल उसको फॉलो करो ई
बुक्स को करो ना यार क्या
ओके वक स्टेशन अवेलेबल नहीं है सर ऑफिशियल
वेबसाइट पर क्या तुम बात कर रहे हो यार
कुछ भी बोलते हो तुम लोग स्टेशन अवेलेबल
नहीं है देखो यहां पे वीएम वेर वर्क
स्टेशन प्रो कैसे अवेलेबल नहीं है यार तुम
लोग कुछ भी बोल देते हो यह क्या है भाई
डाउनलोड र वर्क स्शन प्र इस पर जाओ यहां
पर यह रहा डाउनलोड v व स्शन 17 प्र फॉर
विंडोज डउनलोड नाउ पर क्लिक करो डाउनलोड
नाउ पर क्लिक करोगे यहां डाउनलोड होना
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा अभी फिलहाल डाउनलोड 3
vmware.com वर्क नहीं कर रहा होस्ट इसलिए
थोड़ी सी इशू आ रही है मेरे ख्याल से इसको
रीलोड करना एक दो बार शायद प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व
हो जाएगी या हो जाएगी बट अभी के लिए ये
डाउन है तो आप इसको अभी नहीं कर पाओगे
लेकिन हां रीलोड करना है यहां से डाउनलोड
कर लोगे सिंपल सा फंडा है अब ये वेबसाइट
ही डाउन है तो क्या कर लोगे प्रो फॉर
लिनिक्स ये वाली हायह होस्ट ही डाउन है तो
इसी प मिलेगी यार कैसे नहीं मिलेगी जब
इनका वेबसाइट है तो मिलेगी कैसे नहीं
ओ बग बाउंट पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग हु इज
बेस्ट तुम लोग कंफ्यूज इतना क्यों पेचीदा
क्यों बनाते हो यार कोई चीज को कि
डिफरेंशिया मेरे को बिल्कुल समझ नहीं आता
कोई पूछता है साइबर सिक्योरिटी एथिकल
हैकिंग में सर क्या डिफरेंस है दोनों में
क्या अच्छी चीज है अरे भाई है माइनर
डिफरेंसेस है ऐसा भी नहीं है कि उसके उसके
कारण तुम्हारी लाइफ रुक जाएगी तुम करियर
नहीं बना पाओगे एक में चले गए तो दूसरा
तुमसे बिल्कुल हट खत्म हो जाएगा इतना
टेंशन मत लो यार पढ़ते जाओ सीखते जाओ ना
माइनर डिफरेंसेस होते हैं सब और कुछ नहीं
होता ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है मैंने बहुत बार
ये सब चीजें
डि फ्रक्स ने बग
बाउंटीज पेड कोर्सेस था वह भी सोच रहा
होगा यह बात तो भाई बिल्कुल सही है
तुम्हारी ललित कि बग
बाउंटीज में ना अपन ने कुछ तो काम किया है
क्या लगता है आपको आपको आपको लगता है ऐसा
कि बग बाउंटीज के केस में स्पेशली हमारे
चैनल पर कुछ ना कुछ हमने तो किया है
बढ़िया वाला काम किया खतरनाक वाला काम
किया जिससे बहुत सारे लोग परेशान है
बेचारे इनफैक्ट मुझे तो कई सारे प्रूफ
मिले हैं कि लोग परेशान है इ कोई मुझे बता
के आ बता देता है कोई मेरा स्टूडेंट है
बता देता है कहीं से कोई बंदा है वह बता
देता है कि सर देखो यह स्क्रीनशॉट देख लो
देखो परेशान है सामने वाले लोग बग बाउंटीज
को लेके 10000 की कोर्स जो बेच रहे हैं वह
5000 कर दिया 5000 वाले 3000 कर दिया 3000
वाले जो कोर्स है उसको 1000 कर दिया जो
1000 वाले कोर्स थे उन्होंने कोर्स ही कर
दिया क्योंकि उनके में कुछ था ही नहीं तो
वो चीज वो चीज तो हमने कुछ किया है
भाई यह तो मैं भी मानता
हूं या रियल वर्ल्ड बग हंटिंग पढ़ो बढ़िया
चीज है बढ़िया बुक है बढ़िया बुक है
हाउ टू डाउनलोड मेटा एक्सप्लोइट आईएसओ
फाइल जाओ गल करो डाउनलोड मेटा एक्सप्लोइट
मेटा एक्सप्लोइटेबल की बात कर रहे होगे
तुम मेटा एक्सप्लोइट क्या मेटा
एक्सप्लोइटेबल की बात कर रहे होगे मेरे
ख्याल से मेटा एक्प्ट तो डायरेक्ट आ ही जा
रहा है तुम्हारा काली होली में मिल
जाएगा अ सर हैकर वन में कोई भी टारगेट में
सर बक्स ही नहीं मिलता ऐसा थोड़ी ना है यह
गलतफहमी है हैकर वन पे भी टारगेट्स पे
बग्स फाइंड अ बग्स मिलते हैं यार लोगों को
बिल्कुल मिलते
हैं सही से प्रॉपर्ली चूज करोगे तो
मिलेगा
whatsapp2 25 है ग्रुप का यह बोल रहा है
मेरे को कि मैं बढ़ा दूं यार मैं कैसे
बढ़ाऊ यार लिमिट मैं
तो बढ़ा देता भाई तुमने बोला और यहां 1024
से 2048 कर देता
मैं ओके सर आई एम ओनली 16 इयर्स एंड यू
चेंज माय
लाइफ आई रिपोर्ट 20 बक्स एंड अर्न
00 थैंक्स आई वांट टू मीट यू प्लीज आई एम
फ्रॉम नेपाल अरे भाई क्या बात है बीबीए
मेन अल्फा क्या बात है भाई अब भाई यह जो
भी है ब
देखो मजा आ गया इसके मैसेज को पढ़ के सर
आई एम फ्रॉम 16 इयर्स का बंदा है 20 बक्स
इसने रिपोर्ट किए 00 तक इसने उससे अर्न कर
लिए हैं एंड फ्रॉम नेपाल नेपाल से हो मेनी
मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन भाई सबसे पहले और अपना
नाम भी बता दो जरा कि कौन हो नेपाल में
कहां से हो ताकि लोगों को भी पता चले एंड
इफ
पॉसिबल
अपना लिंक भी दे दो या कहीं लिंकन प डालो
अपनी उस वलने बिलिटी के बारे में या जो भी
है तो हमें टैक करो डिफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी
को लिंकन पे तो हमें पता चल जाएगा ठीक है
एंड इस अचीवमेंट के लिए वेरी ह्यूज
कांग्रेचुलेशन
डज एआई इफेक्ट साइबर सिक्योरिटी वीडियोस
अगर देखते होगे तो तुम्हें मैंने बताया
हुआ है ऑलरेडी कुछ इफेक्ट इफेक्ट नहीं
होने वाली है पहली बात साइबर सिक्योरिटी
का एआई से थोड़ा बहुत इंपैक्ट पड़ेगा अलग
तरीके से पड़ेगा लेकिन जब एआई है
टेक्नोलॉजी जितनी हाई टेक्नोलॉजी जितनी
अच्छी बनेगी उसके एक्सप्लोइटेशन के चांस
भी बढ़ेंगे और उसके मिटिगेशन एंड काउंटर
मेजर के लिए और भी चीजें लानी पड़ेंगी और
बग हंटर्स या सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस फिर भी
यूज में
आएंगे ठीक
है सर मैंने टू मंथ्स कंप्लीट करने कर लिए
है मेरे दोस्त को भी दिक्कत क्या दिक्कत
भा मतलब समझ नहीं
या सर आप इतना
है मतलब यही तो चीजें मेरे को आती है
एक्चुअल में मैं सही बता रहा हूं मेरे को
यही एक चीज आती है
कॉम्प्लेक्शन था उसको मेरा प्रोफेशन बना
लिया टीचिंग मेरा कोई प्रोफेशन नहीं था
पहले आप सबको शायद नहीं पता होगा मैंने
जॉब भी किया है कंपनी में दिल्ली के कंपनी
में मैंने जॉब किया है इनफैक्ट मैंने अ दो
तीन जगह जॉब की है तीन जगह मेरे कॉलेज के
बाद दो तो कंपनीज में मैंने जॉब की है
प्रॉपर जनरली जो जॉब होती है
वीपीटी का ही जॉब था वो एंड कुछ और भी
चीजें थी उसमें कुछ डार्क टाइप जॉब था
डार्क इन द सेंस की जो काम मैं करता था
दैट वाज नॉट दैट मच लीगल मैं बोलूंगा लीगल
इलीगल दोनों था मिक्स अप था ऐसा ही था एंड
एक जॉब मैंने फिर दूसरी जॉब की फिर तीसरी
जॉब की तो मैंने जॉब भी करे बट मेरे को जब
बाद में पता चला एक जॉब मैंने जो किया
ट्रेनिंग का तो मेरे को तब एहसास हुआ कि
मैं चीजों को इजली समझा सकता हूं और मैं
पर वीडियोस भी डालता ही था तो मेरे को
अंदर से वो वो थी कॉन्फिडेंस थी कि लोगों
को इजली समझा पाता हूं देन मैंने उसी को
प्रोफेशन भी बना दिया देन आई बिकम अ
ट्रेनर लव डेनिक्स थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक
यू शेयर्ड होस्टिंग में सब वेबसाइट का
आईपी सेम होता है क्या अरे डोमेन अलग है
भाई क्या तुम लोग भी यार डोमेन
पॉइंट जो करोगे ट इज डिफरेंट
ना होस्टिंग जो एक होस्टिंग होगी ना अलग
अलग एक सर्वर होगा उसकी आईपी तो सेम होगी
ना एंड उस पर मल्टीपल डोमेन होस्ट हो सकते
हैं ठीक है यह चीज होती है ओके एक सेकंड
एक
सेकंड सर आपको पेमेंट कितना था पहले जो
मेरी जॉब थी उसमें मेरी पेमेंट थी 000 पर
मंथ मतलब 000 की सैलरी थी पहली वाली जो
मेरी जॉब थी दूसरी वाली जो जॉब थी उसमें
मेरी 16000 थी 16 हा तीसरी जो जब थी उसम
मेरी 00 थी
00 तो बस उसके बाद तो मैंने खाली छोड़ ही
दिया व भी वो भी टाइम पर नहीं मिल पाती थी
सही से उसके बाद आई लेफ्ट द जॉब मतलब जॉब
करना जॉब ही करना छोड़ दिया फिर
तो फाइल अपलोड वलने बिलिटी का थोड़ा
आईडिया दे दीजिए अरे ला रहा हूं मैं फाइल
अपलोड वलने बिलिटी का एक पूरा क्लास लेकर
आ रहा हूं टेंशन नहीं लेने
का इज प्लेइंग सीटीएफ गुड फॉर बिगिनर्स
एब्सलूट गुड फॉर बिगिनर्स एब्सलूट बेस्ट
फॉर बिगिनर्स
सर मेरा नेम आयुष ने पने न्यू पेन न्यू
पेन है ओके आयुष आयुष
ग्रेट एक बार अपने होम का टूर का ब्लॉग
दीजिए भाई इतना अच्छा मेरा होम है नहीं कि
मैं टूर का बलग दू बढ़िया अगर कोई घर
लूंगा अच्छा सा तो जरूर
दूंगा आपका अभी मंथली सैलरी कितना है अरे
भाई तुम मेरा मंथली सैलरी क्यों पूछ रहे
हो यह बताओ यह बंदा पूछ रहा है एफबीएल
इपिक मेरा मंथली सैलरी कितना है मेरा
मंथली सैलरी तुम क्यों पूछ रहे हो भाई
अभी मंथली सैलरी क्यों पूछ रहे हो भाई
मेरा मंथली सैलरी जानना है क्या तुम लोगों
को सर आप एक बग में 20 के निकाल लेते हो
यह सब तो मैं कुछ ज्यादा कुछ देखो जो चीज
डिस्कस नहीं करनी है वह नहीं करनी
है इट्स डी सर का दो लाख है बहुत बहुत
क्लोज है टडी वेरी क्लोज
ग्राफ कल
आएगा आएगा भाई
आएगा भाई आप प्राइस टेंपरिंग का सेफ मेथड
बताओ ना कैसे परफॉर्म करें विदाउट एनी
रिस्क भाई पहली बात तो सेफ मेथड क्यों यूज
करना है आप कोई गलत काम थोड़ी ना कर रहे
हो आप तो बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स पर हंट कर
रहे हो उसमें प्राइस टेंपरिंग फाइंड कर
रहे हो वो तो वैलिड है लीगल है वहां पर
क्या से वहा नॉर्मल आईपी से करो भाई
परमिशन दी हुई है वो लेबिलिटी है रिपोर्ट
करो अब तुम प्राइस टपिंग का यूज करके
गिफ्ट कार्ड चुराने की कोशिश कर रहे हो या
सोच रहे हो या कोई इलीगल काम करने की सोच
रहे हो यह तो भाई फिर पढ़ोगे पछड़ में
अच्छे वाले और प्राइस टेंपिंग वाली चीज
में अगर कोई ज्यादा एक्टिव दिखता है और
होता है व जेल जाता है उसके अलावा कोई
ऑप्शन नहीं है अगर पकड़ पकड़ में आ गया तो
सच में बहुत लोग गए हैं जेल इस चक्कर में
याद रखिएगा तो यह गलतफहमी ये इसमें मत
पढ़ना कि कुछ नहीं होगा उसमें मैं भी नहीं
बचा
सकता अभी आप जॉब पर होते तो तो आपकी सैलरी
क्या होती अच्छा जॉब पर होते सर एक बात
बताऊं देखो मैं पहली बात तो मैं जॉब नहीं
करता लेकिन मैं सैलरी ड्रो करता हूं यह
बात सही है क्योंकि मैं सैलरी कहां से
ड्रो करता हूं मैं डिफ्रॉक से ही ड्रो
करता हूं इवन एज अ डायरेक्टर एज अ फाउंडर
भी सैलरी ड्र करते हैं लोग वही सैलरी मैं
ड्र करता हूं दैट एज इट इज सिंपल बाकी
बहुत ज्यादा सैलरी नहीं लेता मैं बाकी चीज
बाकी जो ज्यादातर जो है वो मार्केटिंग और
इन सब में एक्सपेंड करते हैं हम लोग एंड
बात की जॉब की तो बहुत सारे जॉब्स मैंने
छोड़े हुए हैं अच्छे अच्छे जॉब्स छोड़े
हुए हैं कुछ करके छोड़े कुछ ऐसे ही पहले
ही छोड़ दिए
मैंने आपको अगर नहीं पता तो अनअकैडमी के
लिए भी काम किया हुआ है फिर मैंने उसको
छोड़ भी दिया था एंड वहां पर जो सैलरी थी
वह
000 के आसपास थी जी हां 000 सैलरी फिक्स
सैलरी थी वो प्लस जो भी बोनस एंड जो भी
चीजें थी वह सारी चीजें फिर भी आई लेफ्ट द
जॉब मतलब मैंने छोड़ दिया वो क्योंकि वहां
पर कुछ कॉम्प्लिकेशंस हो रहे थे उनका कहना
है कि कहना था कि भाई आप जो कर रहे हो
उसको छोड़ो हमारे साथ आ जाओ कंपलीटली मतलब
उधर निकलो और हमारे साथ आ जाओ तो यह तो
पॉसिबल नहीं है ना जब इतने मेहनत से इतने
सालों से
इतनी मतलब इतना टाइम देके कुछ बिल्ड किया
है कुछ फॉर्म किया है कुछ बनाया है उसको
मैं अगर एक लाख सैलरी के लिए छोड़ दूं तो
मुझे लगता है कि आई एम नॉट अ स्टेबल
पर्सन
एंड कैसे छोड़ सकते हैं वो इतने सालों की
मेहनत तो इसलिए मैंने वह जॉब छोड़ दी तो
जरूरी नहीं है कि आप भी ऐसा काम करो या आप
भी छोड़ो एक लाख रप पर मंथ सैलरी बहुत
बहुत अच्छी सैलरी होती है तो अगर आपको
मिलती है तो जरूर करना आप ठीक है
ब्लैक आर्च लाइनक्स आई वांट टू नो मैंने
ब्लैक आच लाइनक्स खुद ही ज्यादा यूज नहीं
किया हुआ है तो उस पर ज्यादा कुछ मैं आपको
अभी क्लासेस तो नहीं ला
सकता भाई अगर आप इस लाइन में नहीं होते तो
क्या करते अगर मैं इस लाइन में नहीं होता
तो मैं पक्का से
100% ट्राई करता मॉडलिंग का लाइक मेरे को
मॉडलिंग की जो लाइन है मॉडलिंग थोड़ा सा
मतलब नमेंट वर्ल्ड जो है एक तरह से बोलो
बॉलीवुड वर्ल्ड जो है गंदा है बट क्या
करूं अच्छा लगता है तो मैं उधर जरूर ट्राई
ट्राई तो जरूर मारता होता ना होता अलग बात
है बट ट्राई मारता सर मीट अप इन पाकिस्तान
अरे यार इंडिया में कर लो पहले तो
पाकिस्तान में क बुलाओगे पटना मीटअप जल्दी
करेंगे भाई टेंशन नहीं लेने
का अच्छा मुझे यह बताओ अगर दिल्ली के अंदर
मीटअप होती है दिल्ली या नोएडा में कहीं प
भी मीटअप अगर करते हैं तो आप में से कितने
लोग वहां पे आ पाएंगे अभी नहीं आने वाले
टाइम में कितने लोग आ सकते हैं दिल्ली या
नोएडा के एरिया में मीट अप करते हैं
तो सर आई एम स्टडिंग बीटेक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी योर कंटेंट इज वेरी गुड एंड इन
आवर कॉलेज नो वन इज टीचिंग लाइक यू थैंक
यू सैयद फैज थैंक यू सो मच भाई इतना अगर
आपको लगता है ऐसा तो दिल्ली और नोटा का
बताओ
यार सर मीटअप के लिए मैं आऊंगा महाराष्ट्र
से क्या बात है थैंक धन्यवाद
भाई
अरे यूपी तो नोएडा यूपी में ही है
यार ठीक है काफी लोग हैं मतलब ओके ओके टेक
फैक्ट
है अजय गिरवाल तानिया
भारद्वाज श्रियांश है एंड शमीम तो है ही
ठीक है मतलब मेनी पीपल आर देयर राइट
दिल्ली में मीटअप का हम करेंगे दिल्ली
मीटअप मैं प्लान कर रहा हूं मेरे दिमाग
में बहुत टाइम से दिल्ली मीटअप चलर बहुत
टाइम से चल रहा है बहुत टाइम से चल रहा है
ऐसा दिल्ली मेट तो मैं करूंगा
इसको कब तक चलेगी बग बांटी की क्लास चलती
जाएगी भाई उसका अभी एंड मुझे खुद नहीं पता
है कब तक चलेगी बग बांटी की क्लासेस में
100 वीडियोस एटलीस्ट आएंगी कम से कम मैं
ये नहीं बोल कि मैक्सिमम 100 वीडियो ही
आएंगी या टोटल 100 वीडियो आएंगी ना
एटलीस्ट 100 वीडियोस आएंगी उसके बाद और भी
आ सकती
है बिहार पटना प्लीज बिल्कुल
बहुत बेस्ट है धन्यवाद भाई बनारस आओ सर जी
बनारस वाराणसी आएंगे भाई
आएंगे सर एक बार नेक्स्ट टारगेट लाइव हंट
में हैकर बकट से ले लीजिए ठीक है ले लेंगे
कोई दिक्कत नहीं कहीं से ले
लो भाई फोन से काली नेट हंटर यूज करके
बड़े बड़े बग्स फाइंड कर सकते हैं कि नहीं
कोई भी बग फाइंड नहीं कर सकते भाई अरे यार
बेकार की चीज है ये सब मत करो ये फोन से
यह वो ठीक है फोन से जितना कर स हो करो
ठीक है चलेगा नहीं है लैपटॉप क्या कर सकते
हैं लेकिन लैपटॉप लेना है यार लैपटॉप
जरूरी है लैपटॉप लेना ही पड़ेगा यह
गलतफहमी मत रहो कि फोन से सारे काम तुम
लैपटॉप वाले कर लोगे ठीक है आगे चलके कुछ
ऐसा आ जाता है कि फोन में ही तुम्हारा
लैपटॉप स्क्रीन आ गया सब कुछ आ गया कर रहे
हो अलग दैट इज द डिफरेंट थिंग बट स्टिल
अभी लैपटॉप चाहिए
भाई सर 100 वीडियोस तक
आप हमको टॉप 10 बनाकर हां भाई बिल्कुल
अजय गरेवाल आपने कहां तक कौन से डे तक के
वीडियोस कंप्लीट किया जाए गरेवाल
बताइए
आ अ कभी कोलकाता में भी आए आपको रोसगुल्ला
और मिस्टी रोसगुल्ला एंड मिस्टी दो दो ही
खिलाएंगे अरे भाई यह तो मैंने बहुत सुना
हुआ है इसके बारे में कोलकाता बंगाल का
रसगुल्ला मिस्टी दोही यह सब चीज बहुत सुनी
है और ब्लॉगिंग वगैरह जो हो करते हैं लोग
क्रिएटर्स उनके ब्लॉग में भी देखने को मिल
जाता है तो काफी पॉपुलर है वहां पर जरूर
अगर आया तो
जरूर खाऊंगा तो
जरूर सर अगर सेम लेबिलिटी डिफरेंट पर्सन
रिपोर्ट करता है इन सेम कंपनी डज इट वैलिड
और नॉट वल्नरेबल क्या पूछ रहे हो भाई क्या
पूछ के रहे हो सेम वलने बिलिटी अगर
रिपोर्ट करता है अगर दो लोग रिपोर्ट करते
सेम वा जिसका पहले जाएगा उसका कडर होगा
बाकी दूसरे का डुप्लीकेट जाएगा
सिंपल सर आपने दूसरे बग बांटी पढ़ाने
वालों का निवाला छीन लिया ऐसा कुछ नहीं है
मैंने निवाला किसी का नहीं छीना है भाई
मैंने किसी का कोई निवाला नहीं छीना है और
मैं किसी को बुरा नहीं बोल रहा ना किसी को
मैं डिग्रेड कर रहा हूं जो भी फेलो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट्स हैं हमारे जो भी इस
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी के पार्ट हैं
जो भी दूसरे एथिकल हैकर्स हैं हैकर्स हैं
रिसर्चस है दे ऑल आर वेरी गुड वेरी वेल
इक्विप्ड विद द नॉलेज दे आर हैविंग दे आर
वेरी टैलेंटेड इन देर रिस्पेक्टिव डोमेंस
रिस्पेक्टिव टॉपिक्स और समथिंग लाइक दैट
तो यू शुड डेफिनेटली रिस्पेक्ट देम आल्सो
एंड उनका कंटेंट अगर जानदार है तो उनका
कंटेंट लोग पेड भी लेंगे सीधी सी बात है
मैं तो इतना ही बोलता हूं कि मैं फ्री
ट्रेनिंग दे रहा हूं साब बग बाउंटीज की
लेकिन अगर आपका कंटेंट बहुत अच्छा है तो
आपके पेड ट्रेनिंग में भी लोग जाएंगे मैं
इतना ही मानता हूं लेकिन मैं इतना यह भी
बोलता हूं कि इस ट्रेनिंग को अगर जो
सिंसियर फॉलो कर रहा है और खुद से थोड़ी
एक्सप्लोरेशन कर रहा है तो दूसरी ट्रेनिंग
की मुझे जहां तक लगता है जरूरत नहीं
पड़ेगी उसको क्योंकि उस लेवल की चीजें दी
जा रही है
इसमें ठीक
है कौन-कौन चाहता है डि फनिक सर गिव अवे
करे पहली भाई डिफ्रॉक सर कौन है पहले यह
बताओ डि फोनिक सर कहां से पैदा हो गए डि
फ्रोक सर तो कोई है नहीं डि फोनिक्स इ नॉन
लिविंग थिंग तो डिफक सर कहां से हो
गए सर बट व स्कैमर से आपने जल्दी बचाया
सबको नहीं तो उसने वेबीनार अपलोड करके
सबको पागल ही कर दिया था बिल्कुल कोई बात
नहीं
स आपकी ट्रेनिंग ट्रेडिंग ट्रेनिंग तगड़ी
है नेक्स्ट लेवल थैंक यू सही थैंक यू थैंक
यू सर योर फेस एंड आदित्य राज कश्यप इज
सेम लाइक कौन है भाई आदित्य राज कश्यप
मुझे नहीं पता आदित्य राज कश्यप कौन है
भाई वो भी बताओ जिसकी मेरे दे मतलब मेरी
जैसी फेस
है वो भी बताओ भाई कौन है आई डोंट नो
स आपकी वजह से सर एई की वजह से जॉब जाएगी
क्या ना कोई नहीं जॉब जाएगी बट एई को एई
को सीखना शुरू कर दो बग बाउटी पर और कितने
वीडियोस आएंगे अभी तो 100 प्लस वीडियोस
रहेंगे
आएंगे आप समझे किसके बारे में बोल रहा
नहीं
यार ब्रो कोडिंग इ इंपोर्टेंट फॉर एथिकल
हैकिंग अ एंड व्हिच लैंग्वेज वी शुड लर्न
देखो कोडिंग प्रोग्रामिंग इज रिलेटिवली
इंपॉर्टेंट है एट अ स्टार्ट लेवल तो नहीं
है बिल्कुल एस अ बिगनर लेवल पे उतना कुछ
खास इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है इंपॉर्टेंट रोल
प्ले नहीं करता है आपके बक बाउटी जर्नी
में या साइबर सिक्योरिटी जर्नी में लेकिन
एक एक लेवल प जब आप पहुंचो ग तो वहां पे
आपको कोडिंग की जरूरत पड़ेगी पड़ सकती है
ठीक है देन आप जा सकते हो अलग-अलग
लैंग्वेजेस हैं मैं सबसे ज्यादा ऑलवेज टॉप
प्रायोरिटी पर पाइथन को ही रखता हूं अभी
भी अभी भी मेरा चेंज नहीं हुआ पाइथन ही
रहेगा क्योंकि पाइथन की स्केल और पाइथन की
जो लाइक फीचर्स है ना उसको बहुत लोग
अंडरस्टीमेट भी कर देते हैं नहीं जानते
शायद पाइथन इ वेरी वेरी खतरनाक लैंग्वेज
बहुत डेंजरस लैंग्वेज है कुछ भी कर सकते
हो उसके अंदर में एनीथिंग
समझे तो गो विथ दैट मेरे ख्याल से पहले
फिर दूसरे लैंग्वेजेस है यू कैन गो विद ट
आल्सो आर के साथ भी जा सकते हो रस्ट के
साथ भी जा सकते हो डिपेंड करता
आप सर सी प्लस प्लस आता है मुझे क्या मेरी
हेल्प करेंगे कौन सी हेल्प करूं भाई सी
प्लस प्लस में और सी और सी प्स प्लस को
मेरे से दूर रखो भाई यह दोनों से मुझे
बहुत दिक्कत
है हाउ डू आई गेट स्टार्टेड इन बग बाउटी
हंटिंग प्लीज आई हैव मेड ऑलरेडी अ वीडियो
ऑन दिस प्लीज वच दैट वीडियो प्लीज
वच नेपाल में मीटअप करते हैं नेपाल में आओ
सर अरे आएंगे भाई नेपाल तो पास में ही है
मेरे यहां से नेपाल की जो डिस्टेंस है वो
1.5 आवर्स की है बाइ आर डेढ़ घंटे की तो
नेपाल इज नॉट फार अवे फ्रॉम माय होम
करेंटली जहां पर मैं
हूं हां जी हां जी सर जैसे यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड
क्या है सर जैसे यूजर नेम पासवर्ड मिलती
है रेकन में तो वह किसका आईडी है वह कैसे
पता करेंगे कि किसका लॉगिन क्रेडेंशियल है
वह जहां पर सबमिट अरे मैसेज डिलीट हो गया
इसका अच्छा भाई स्पैम मत करो यार एक दो
बार मैसेज करो ज्यादा बढ़िया यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड ऐसे मिलता है आपको ना तो कहीं पर
एकन में तो आपको देखना है ना भाई कि वह
किससे रिलेटेड है यही तो आपको फाइंड कर
यही तो फाइंड करना है कौन सी कंपनी कौन सी
पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम से रिलेटेड है व
फाइंड करना है वो
तो वो मिल जाएगा तो रिपोर्ट
करोगे सर वाइटी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
कम्युनिटी साथ में पॉडकास्ट क्यों नहीं
करते क्योंकि वाइटी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
कम्युनिटी में यूनिटी नहीं है एक्चुअली
शायद जहां तक मुझे लगता है कुछ खास यूनिटी
नहीं है जब मिलते हैं तभी यूनिटी है जब
नहीं मिलते तो कुछ पता ही नहीं है सब बिजी
है अपने आप में तो अगर ऐसा कुछ हुआ तो
जरूर होगा एंड एक पॉडकास्ट में लेकर जल्दी
आऊंगा हमारे अनिल भाई के साथ तो उस परे हम
बहुत सारी बातें करेंगे वह आपके लिए
मजेदार
होगा हां इंडियन में थोड़ी सी दिक्कत है
यार पता नहीं इंडिया में क्या दिक्कत
है करेक्ट
बोला स वीडियोज में ज्यादा टाइम मिल जा
रहा है हां ठीक है ना कोई दिक्कत नहीं ना
मजे करो यार सीखो रिलैक्स करो रिपीट
करो हां जी हां जी हां जी वही अनिल भाई की
बात करूं मैं बिल्कुल बिल्कुल पॉडकास्ट
छोटी वही अनिल अनिल भाई की वही अनिल भाई
सर व्हेन यू स्टार्ट योर कंपनी फ्रॉम
व्हिच लेवल ऑफ इन्वेस्टमेंट यू स्टार्टेड
लाइक मोर देन 5 लाख सबसे पहली बात तो
हमारी कंपनी जो अभी चल रही है इसमें कोई
इन्वेस्टमेंट हमने रेज नहीं किया खुद का
ही हां खुद का इन्वेस्टमेंट है बूट स्टैप
है हम
एंड बहुत ज्यादा इन्वेस्टमेंट नहीं है अभी
तक हमारा तो कमी इन्वेस्टमेंट है एंड उस
परे रिटर्न भी अच्छा मिल जाता है तो वी आर
कंसीडरिंग फॉर द इन्वेस्टमेंट राउंड अ
वेरी रिसेंटली लाइक कुछ हम करेंगे अभी
ऑफलाइन के लिए हमें उसके पहले
इन्वेस्टमेंट राउंड करके ही ऑफलाइन आएंगे
हम डेल्ली नोएडा
में सर जी बग बाउंट क्या होता है बग बाउंट
बग बांटी क्या सर जी बग बाउंट क्या होता
है बग बाउंट एक चिड़िया का नाम है जिसमें
कि
आप बेसिकली बग बाउंट में जोक सपाट मैं बता
देता हूं अगर आपको नहीं पता है तो बग
बाउंटीज के अंदर में आप क्या करते हैं
एक प्रोग्राम एक कंपनी होती है उनके
एसेट्स होते हैं डिजिटल एसेट्स उनको
सिक्योर करने की कोशिश करते हैं उनके अंदर
की लेबिलिटी को फाइंड करके एंड उसके लिए
वह आपको अलाउ करते हैं आपको एक
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर पॉलिसी के तहत
आपको उनको लेबिलिटी फाइंड करके उस
पर्टिकुलर डिजिटल एसेट में उनको इफॉर्म
करना होता है और वह खुश हो जाते हैं उस
इंफॉर्मेशन से क्योंकि आपने उनके
एप्लीकेशन को आपने उनके एसेट्स को सिक्योर
करा है सिक्योर करने में हेल्प करा है
हैकर्स से तो खुशी खुशी आपको कुछ प्रसाद
देते हैं एंड उस प्रसाद के अंदर हॉल ऑफ
फेम हो सकता है रिवर्ड हो सकता है बाउंट
हो सकती है पैसे हो सकते हैं बहुत सी चीज
हो सकते
है बग बंटी पूछा था क्या अरे बग बंटी तो
मुझे भी नहीं
[संगीत]
पता को पकड़ला
चलिए बढ़िया बढ़िया हा और आपके कोई हां
बिल्कुल सही बोला बिल्कुल सही बोला शमीम
ने भी आपके कोई फीडबैक सजेशन है तो प्लीज
पुट पुट ट डाउन इन द चैट सेक्शन सो दैट वी
कैन इंप्रूव हम उसको देखें समझे कि भाई
क्या है एक्चुअली आपका कोई फीडबैक या
सजेशन है तो और इस चैट के पिंड मैसेज में
देखिए एड पन टेस्टिंग ट्रेनिंग की लिंक दी
गई है अभी भी टाइम है कल तक ऑफर प्राइस
में फटाफट इनरोल कर लीजिए जल्दी से परसों
ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट हो रही है 18 में
से क्या बात है 120 लाइक्स कर दिए अरे मजा
आ गया भाई खुश कर दिया तुम लोगों ने आज न
धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद चलो
अ फीडबैक क्या है सर ओस टॉप 10 समझा दे
कुछ समझ नहीं आ यह फीडबैक थोड़ी ना होता
है या यह तो तुम्हारी डिमांड हो गई कि हां
भाई व प्र को समझा दीजिए अच्छे से या कुछ
ऐसा सजेशन फीडबैक तो यह नहीं हुआ ठीक है
ओके करेंगे डोंट वरी
डोंट वरी ब्रदर करेंगे
करेंगे चलो तो काफी सारे क्वेश्चन हमने ले
लिए ऑलरेडी लोग मॉडर्न वेब आर्किटेक्चर के
ऊपर वीडियो ठीक है पल्लब य तो लाऊंगा वो
तो मैंने बोला भी
था तो गाइस आई
थिंक ठीक है आई थिंक गाइस आज का सेशन बस
इतना ही रखते हैं एंड डाउट सेशन के लिए
काफी कुछ हमने डिस्कस किया डाउट सेशन के
अंदर में काफी कुछ आपके सवालों के जवाब
दिए कुछ सवाल आपके रह गए होंगे कोई बात
नहीं नेक्स्ट डाउट सेशन में हम उसको
क्लियर करेंगे पूछेगा ठीक है एंड
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद डाउट सेशन में आपके
यहां पर अपनी उपस्थिति दर्ज करने के लिए
क्योंकि क्योंकि काफी लोग आए हैं डाउट
सेशन में एंड अगेन मैं फिर से बोल रहा हूं
चैट सेक्शन में पिन लिंक है de.com
dc5 से स्टार्ट हो रही है तो आपके पास एक
गोल्डन अपॉर्चुनिटी है अभी भी इनरोल करने
का ऑफर फी में ही आप इनरोल कर पाएंगे सारी
डिटेल्स यहां दी हुई है डिटेल्स देख
लीजिएगा यहां पे सिंपल डाउनलोड यहां
सिलेबस है सिलेबस देख लीजिएगा डाउनलोड प
क्लिक कीजिएगा सिलेबस ओपन हो जाएगा पूरा
प्रीबुक करके यहां पे आप इनरोल कर सकते
हैं एंड आपको टू टाइम्स में ही पेमेंट
करनी है फ्लैट 50 पर का डिस्काउंट अभी
फिलहाल मिल रहा है ओरिजिनल प्राइस जो
14000 की थी हम इसको अभी 7000 में आपको
अवेल करा रहे हैं एंड उसमें भी आपको 3500
ही पे करना है फर्स्ट में फर्स्ट
इंस्टॉलमेंट सेकंड इंस्टॉलमेंट इज
2500 सॉरी 3500 आफ्टर 15 डेज एंड अगर आप
वन टाइम पेमेंट करना चाहते हैं तो आप इसको
टिक कर देंगे तो यहां पे आपको 6500 ही
ओनली पे करनी है फुल ठीक है
दैट्ची फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन थैंक यू सो सो
मच फॉर अ कमिंग लाइव हम जल्दी मिलेंगे
नेक्स्ट लाइव और नेक्स्ट क्लास में तब तक
के लिए सबको गुड नाइट टाटा बाय बाय टेक
केयर एंड हैव अ गुड स्लीप धन्यवाद सभी को
टाटा